[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
laughs
nothing is faster and more exhilarating
in chess than a bullet game it's all
about quick thinking and taking
advantage of every opportunity when it
comes blink and you'll miss it how did
he do that despite his popularity bullet
chess only has one annual championship
tournament and now entering its fifth
year the bullet Chess Championship is
stronger than ever three-time Champion
Hikaru Nakamura again looks to defend
his title and add to his impressive
trophy case a brutal finish
officially as one the only player who
has ever stopped Nakamura in this event
also returns to take another shot at it
2021 Champion alireza farugia that's it
competing with these champions for the
first time in the format the best
all-around player in the world Magnus
Carlson has dominated chess seemingly
forever but he's never played in the
bullet Chess Championship will one of
these big three of bullet take home the
twenty thousand dollar crown or can
someone else claim the title maybe Nara
ditsky Tang Hansen Carolina
that is the Fabiano finale in this
speediest of speed chess championships
only one Champion will emerge
welcome to the 2023 bullet Chess
Championship
[Music]
happy International Chess Day and
welcome back to the bullet Chess
Championship 2023. I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me is once again
Grandmaster Simon Williams Simon we
missed you yesterday hope you had a nice
day off what'd you get up to
uh yeah thanks Robert and happy chest
Day to everyone uh it's good to
celebrate our favorite game I am I
supposed to be doing a simultaneous at a
club but it got canceled so I actually
watched the dodgy horror film instead uh
Robert so uh it was uh kind of relaxing
uh but it's good to be back uh looking
at this uh crazy but exciting tournament
and Robert I heard I I missed some
action yesterday as well oh you
certainly did and I'm a fan of horror
movies as well so no need to be ashamed
don't judge us everybody in chat but
yesterday there it was a blood bath or
two it the bullet Chess Championship so
let's look at the bracket remind you of
what happened yesterday uh that
bloodbath was Andrew Tang taking down
Eric Hampton by a score of 14-3 that was
a very a one-sided matchup Andrew Tang
of course he is known for his bullet
chess prowess there was a DQ Amino honey
and he couldn't make it he was in
transportation so Bortnick moves on uh
pravian I think he's been the Underdog
Story of the event he beat minlay who
who took Magnus Carlson a task a day
before that and of course Jose Martinez
he beat Dennis lesvik while in the
winter semifinals that's where much the
excitement was at the end of yesterday's
session Nakamura takes down naroditsky
and we had a really hotly contested
match between farugia and Carlson the
youngster now playing for France he took
down the long time world number one so
Simon that sets us up for a fantastic
day of Chess today we will start in the
losers bracket before eventually going
up to the winners final but so many big
names remain in the field and yet we had
to say goodbye to a bunch as well
yeah it was a fascinating day I mean I
was checking very briefly when the film
got a little bit too scary for me uh
actually I don't really get scared by
horror films but I was cheekily checking
my phone because it was such an exciting
day at chess but we got another one
today as you mentioned Robert and we do
start with the losers bracket and that
means that our our first matches today I
think it's our first four matches are
all deaf or Glory if a player loses they
are out of the competition and that is
extra pressure extra attention and it's
going to be a great AHS we're also here
for a while I think we're here for about
four or four or so hours so you guys at
home you can you can settle in get the
popcorn you know save your horror films
for another time because you've got me
and uh Robert to keep you happy yeah
they definitely do indeed because it's
going to be a great day of bullet chess
as you mentioned we will start in the
losers bracket with that matchup between
Bortnick and paravian and we should talk
about Bortnick he didn't actually play
yesterday he made it through via
disqualification or forfeit walkover
whatever you want to call it that's what
happened and he is a star
3367 peakbullet rating on chess.com he
also can dabble over the board winning
the 2023 Charlotte open and I think what
made him more famous in the Chess World
was in 2019 he took down Alexander
grishek and Maxine vasher lagrav in the
bullet Chess Championship he lost to hit
card Nakamura in the final but that is
when Danny wrench he named him Bortnick
strong the flex of the muscles and boric
made it all the way to the final so as
we catch him on camera now Simon he does
have a tough match at paravian but we
know what this man right here is capable
of
Yeah a hundred percent uh botnik has
proved himself time and time again I
mean he's a he's a great player at all
time limits but the shorter uh the time
gets the stronger he becomes he's proven
that just before you know and so it's
going to be it's going to be a very
tough match for David uh but David has
been uh I think shocking some of us
shocking me at least with his victory
over mindly yesterday uh because we have
to remember that men nearly knocked out
Magnus Carlson but
um David destroyed him uh so this one uh
I have to say Bortnick is probably the
favorite going on track record but if
David plays the way that he has been it
could be a very close match David's Peak
bullet rating above 3200 if he's going
to beat Bortnick today that Peak rating
will get even higher but he has had some
great successes of his own not only did
he qualify for this event I believe uh
you know he and Jose Martinez the last
two qualifiers standing in this field he
beat grishook in Las Vegas along the way
but Simon you were there 2020 in
Gibraltar when he won the most
prestigious uh open Event in the world
that's right I've commentated over in
Gibraltar for a long long time it's one
of the strongest open competitions
incredibly difficult to get in the
prizes there let alone win the
competition and that just shows uh the
strength of David and what he's capable
of doing and his skill uh he he's not
your average Grandmaster he's got a lot
of talent and uh clearly when the
pressure is on he performs better and
he's gonna need to use that pressure
today because uh if he loses he's out
but the same goes for Bortnick and uh I
guess you know again how the match
starts is going to be so important in
that one yeah as you're saying pornick
the favorite but in 30 minutes of bullet
really anything could happen in a
matchup like this because private is
that strong and there is a lot at stake
so sometimes players they rise to the
occasion others unfortunately collapse
under the weight of that burden that
pressure and the winner makes it through
to the losers quarterfinals where Daniel
naroditski awaits that's not going to be
an easy matchup for the winner here but
they're guaranteed a cool 6K that is the
good news the loser they're out of the
competition they still get four thousand
dollars for their efforts that's good
prize money but you know they want to
keep on in this event they want that
chance to play against Dania
100 I mean that is a big prize playing
against Dania and um also you know the
difference of two thousand dollars it is
a lot of money I mean in half an hour
how often can you win two thousand
dollars and I'm trying to work out how
many uh dollars that is per minute uh 30
minutes and it's two thousand dollars
I'll let someone in the chat do the
maths
66 and two thirds so 66.66
you're just a genius more horror film
Vibes going on there
that's that's nicely nicely worked out
there Robert really yeah that's that's
not bad cash right per minute I mean uh
wow you know do that for a while and
you'll be swimming in it so so it's a
lot of money and a lot of pressure for
for both of the players but portnooky
seems pretty calm right now I mean he is
the favorite in this matchup he has that
experience that we were talking about
the 2019 runner-up to Hikaru Nakamura he
beat grushook and Maxine Russia lagrav
along the way these are two uh number
four number twos in the world so some of
the best players in chess history it
went down at the mouse of Bortnick and I
say mouse for a reason when he gets in
the scrambles Bortnick is so fast and
paravian he's proven himself along the
way he's taken down super Grand Master
Dimitri on draken and then minlay who
gave Magnus Carlson all he could handle
so paravian is not somebody that you
should underestimate ever again
100 and uh you know we mentioned David's
Victory yesterday against minley and um
the other thing we've got to bear in
mind is that Bortnick didn't have the
match there yesterday so there may be
that extra form uh that you know David's
had more games he's on a roll could play
in his favor and again he is the
underdog I would say just going on track
record but he's gonna need to all that
all that like luck of the role uh using
the pressure well and his past great
results from yesterday and the day
before uh to carry on in the match
that's going to happen very shortly I
think it's a good note though that
boarding didn't play yesterday and
sometimes okay it's one day you're not
going to be super Rusty he's a streamer
he plays all the time but you want to be
in the flow of the event and paravian
he's not just in the flow I mean he's
flowing those victories uh were flowing
the last couple of matches so I feel
like Providence in really good form
right now and it's accumulated over the
last couple days again first he lost the
damn
everyone loses to Daniel naroditski
unless you're Magnus Hikaru and farrugia
but he was giving him a fight so
paravian he's really proven himself over
these last three days and why not a
fourth good day of action from him
100 uh and I and the game seems to have
started which is great uh as before I
think it's gonna be very important to
have this start
um develops and this position here I I'm
I'm happy to see black playing H5
stopping white pushing the H Pawn I
actually lost the game very quickly in
nearly exactly the same opening against
David's um quite recently and he knows
this very very well
um so we saw even Fabiano getting a lot
of problems against his Jabar London
system with the black pieces uh so the
opening stage I think is going to be
rather key Robert in this match this is
a complete opening win for private not
only on the board is he perfectly fine
look at the clock he is up 20 plus
seconds against Bortnick and that's bad
news for boarding if the match is going
into preparation territory is one of the
best prepared players on the planet
yes uh totally agree and um this
position here it probably is fairly even
but if you compare the Bishops Black's
Bishop is just clearly better I think
I'd prefer to be black here and he might
just pick up a pawn now so already going
a pawn up and he needs to start strong
this is one thing we've made clear
because when Bortnick gets going he can
just get a really strong role and uh
that could be another Pawn dropping
there in the board there so looking good
for black yeah what play from paravian
here every move with purpose and he is
up so much time but this is where border
can trick you if you feel like okay I'm
gonna win on the clock and then he gets
into Superman mode and plays at a
lightning Pace I don't think he's gonna
get this one especially with his Jeep on
running off the board but there it is
boarding just picked up a bishop and his
Rook was ready to stop the pawn
yes and black okay black playing for the
win there very brave play will he go for
a draw Now by moving his King backwards
the white Rook Gets behind the pawn and
I think black should have taken the draw
there Robert this is really risky play
uh he's going for the clock though right
two seconds it's enough time for white I
think that private's about to get this
one he just needs to keep his rook and
Pawn on the board he's doing just that
point four seconds and there it is so
parabet does get game one but did you
see Bortnick cut the time deficit from
about 15 seconds to four by the end he
is scary fast and I'm just letting
everybody know if you have not watched
Bortnick play bullet that's what you
should keep your eyes on not these clock
at the start of the game but when both
players get around 15 seconds he gets
into that next gear and it is just so
seriously impressive
yeah yeah he's got the turbo gear
charger it's like uh if you're seeing
Fast and Furious when they put that
stuff in their engine and they press the
button and they take off and that's
that's the turbo gear button you need
the one danger I would say for Bortnick
is maybe his openings a little bit
they're quite predictable he's played
the alakai in here actually he's got a
perfectly good position as black but the
alacrine does have a rather dubious
reputation and surely David has done
some good preparation uh and this
position well it is ending up probably a
bit better for black here with the extra
Pawn
yeah completely agree that black gets to
keep this C Pawn uh it doesn't look like
the best one and now it's wait what that
was just a loss of a piece and it's so
funny how engines are right some this is
equal and I do believe it because it's
only a night for a pawn but not many
pawns remain and they're all on the same
side of the board here White's not gonna
lose it but when you look at this
position you're like yeah black should
win this most of the time
I 100 agree I mean he is two points up
if we're gonna do it by the old school
kind of point system and uh the Knight
is really tricky right Robert especially
in Blitz chess and here there could be a
mating net if the Knight comes down in
front of the Rook the white king could
be in a lot of trouble at the right time
and there you go there's the blunder
that night just proving to be too strong
yup he falls into a fork but as we're
saying there was a mating net as well
very difficult to deal with multiple
threats especially when low on time and
we get this jabala London again so
Bortnick he's even up the match he's
going back to his tried and true opening
but I really feel like paravian he is
going to have the edge as you've been
highlighting in the opening stage of the
game he is so well prepared he loves his
solid openings from the white side with
the black pieces he prepares deeply and
this is a player that as we talked about
you saw him win Gibraltar that's a
classical tournament over the board
where hikar was won that many times and
a lot of super jams play
100 and and you're right about the
opening Robert it's very important to
pick up on how the trends are going in
these quick matches because they're
gonna they could play lots of games in
the same opening position and I feel
I've looked at this line a lot myself
and it's one of the problems with the
Jabara London white is okay but if white
does try to push for the win black gets
lots of counter play against the white
king as we're seeing here whose King is
safer that's the important thing at this
time limit and I think it must be
Black's King which is well much safer in
this position what a decision by
boarding to take on A3 with the pawn I
think he didn't want to give up the G2
Pawn so that's why he ruined his own
Pawn structure but Black's King safe and
sound tucked away who cares about that
extra Pawn no one's counting but the
material but actually I'm about to look
for a Checkmate over here but C2 is
hanging and that may ensure I was gonna
say a draw but he blocks he wants a win
does Bortnick does he want to win yeah I
mean that's a very brave decision the
queen comes back stops all the checks
and it still looks like black should be
doing well here with that PIN on the
white Rook black putting the pressure on
there it's equal a material but again
it's the white king which is in more
danger that's very important at this
time and what a move there Checkmate on
the board and that gives David a lead I
think it could be the opening could be
so important Robert
yes it will be and Bortnick he's played
so many games because he's a streamer
he's playing all the time but paravian
is so well prepared you really can't say
it enough that it's impressive what
paravian does he gets positions he feels
very comfortable in look at this
position it's just an end game where
equal material but you look at the light
Square Bishops it's kind of like a
French for black and that Bishop on D3
it defends everything it also looks into
appears across the board into Black's
position I would say that white
typically has a slight pole but Bishop
B5 playing A4 to A5 I didn't like the
decision from pravin although now that I
say that the Rook on B5 it may have a
little bit of trouble getting back in
the game but it doesn't matter when
you're picking up all these Pawns
yeah I mean it happened so quickly yet
again and the one problem black has here
is that Rook you've pointed out and he's
now trying to get that Rook out of
danger and it should be a safe extra
Pawn for black White's Pawn in the
middle of the board on E5 it's also a
big weakness you can see that one
getting rounded up as well so uh
um in this position so far uh Bortnick
has a great chance to level the score I
think we're going to see a very close
match though which is what we want to
see isn't it close match oh we
definitely do and also we're seeing if
this game concludes the way it looks
like it will afford and it has concluded
a fourth consecutive win for the player
with the black pieces so it goes
probably in Portland
one of them has to stop this trend if
they hope to win this match
and look at this Robert we now see
decide to play E4 he clearly wasn't
happy at the way the opening are going
and I think this is a very wise choice
when things are not going your way
you've got to switch it up that's the
sort of positive about playing the same
opponent you can uh you can prepare
better you can work things out on the
Fly uh but again black has a very
comfortable position here I feel
everything develop Black's Rook comes
into the middle uh only thing I would
say is maybe the black is slightly
weaker than White's King maybe yeah yeah
I mean it does look that way at first
glance but the way that probably is
playing it looks he's showing up as king
safety and I just want to give a shout
out to Bortnick because a lot of chess
players are stubborn that I've done the
research I've prepared for years in this
opening I'm not going to change it no
that's not it's not the opening's fault
I just need to play better he recognized
that paravian was getting good positions
every game that he had the black person
oh look at that tactic Simon if that was
captured The Rook on F2 was losing he
picks up material is on fire right now
with the black pieces
yes he is that was a brilliant spotted
tactic and you can see on the camera
Bortnick very disappointed with missing
that that move and here well obviously
black has the extra Queen he's using
Harry and his pieces are coordinating so
well the white king is just too weak
here it should be Knight G2 we'll finish
it off there you go probably time to
resign just resign
that's saying again yeah the first one
of the day I get the feeling it will
happen more than once especially because
you need to have the gamesmanship down
you need to know when to resign early or
when to keep fighting yesterday in the
second game of Hikaru Nakamura danielski
saved the Lost position down appears by
playing on and he played it forever but
that was early in the match it's still
early in this one over 20 minutes remain
but I think for Bortnick he's just not
feeling comfortable yet because parabian
he has his good opening preparation and
he's not letting bornick off the hook
when Robin has the edge
and as you said it's now five wins in a
row for the black pieces which is very
peculiar normally at this level in chess
uh but uh you know a big big score this
one though I have to say is one of the
only positions where I'm really starting
to prefer white uh because Black's Pawn
in the middle it should be weak that
move has given as a blunder I'm not sure
why it was given as a blunder a bit
above my head there I'm afraid and the
black fighting Batman
and that was a really nice move by
Bortnick to bring his get his Rook
activated and then a nice retreat by
paravian oh oh this is a winning King
and pawn end game somehow and you know
why this Pawn on G6 can't move so even
if you get an extra pawn and look at
this black has an extra opponent on the
king side white has an extra Pawn on the
queen side but only White's pawns get
pushed up the board it is a winning King
and pawn and game for Provident all of a
sudden
100 this could be the first and it
should be the first win for white
White's pawns should Queen on that Queen
side they're much more dangerous why is
he thinking he's just gonna push and
here you go you're gonna see a past Pawn
being made uh any chances of black or
blacks I'm gonna have to get a little
bit lucky here uh but this is gonna give
David if it goes well the way we think
it's going to go a two point lead he's
gonna Queen first he's got 10 seconds
left it should be enough time uh to win
this one and this is where pre-moving
comes in you see proving speed that's a
Checkmate on the spot and Bortnick he's
not he's flustered right now he's like
what am I doing wrong and the answer
really is what is paravian doing right
it's the opening stage it's the
Precision It's The End Game technique
well done for pravin and bornik he goes
back to the jabala London
yeah I mean if anyone wants no good
opening is black against the Jabbar of
London I do recommend they look at this
line that David is playing like I said I
lost horribly to him and myself with
white pieces and it is one of the
critical lines at this moment in time
but in this position I think White's
done a much better job than some of the
other games getting the Queen off I
think helps white because the white King
has been in a lot of trouble and maybe
even that black Rook is gonna start to
look very stupid here
yeah and that's why he sacrifices that's
great recognition by you and by paravin
I don't want that silly Rook I'm gonna
get in trouble and the dark squares down
the line let's just give up that rope
shatter White's Pawn structure but
bornix handled it perfectly he put his
Bishop on C3 no infiltration scores for
the Rook watch out for some checkmating
nets for the king safely scampers into
the middle and I think that Bortnick
with the lead in the clock with extra
material he should be able this is
secure victory
you should be able to and he probably
needs this one otherwise he's gonna go
three points behind so this is an
important important game he's relying on
his C pawn and maybe his a pawn to come
rushing through black does have a bit of
counter play though now on the king side
it's simply a race here isn't it who's
gonna Queen their Pawn First and uh it
looks like white should be winning that
race
he didn't throw in Rook B one check if
he checked the king first there would be
no Rook A5 shutting off the black Rook
from the a file so nicely spotted by
Bortnick uh unfortunate slip that
happens in bullet for paravian that was
a well played game though I think we
have to give bordig the credit for
bouncing back after a couple difficult
defeats
100 and that closes the Gap to one point
only one point in it and uh we see yet
again another sharp ala coin opening and
um so far I I am preferring white in
these in these positions because it
looks like White's King is just the
safer P Set uh that pawn on E5 and front
and White's Bishop often gives white
good attacking chances and now he can
take his Pawn back but I you know I
don't know Bortnick is he's he's proving
that he's changing my mind on the alakai
now thinking maybe I should learn the
other coin maybe maybe this is kind of
an opening for me Robert he's making it
look good he's he does because he
actually works very hard on his openings
and it seems like that was a mistake a
bishop sacrifice if you take it there's
Queen A4 check and that's why he didn't
capture but I'll say about Bortnick is
he created this course on the jabala
London and wow he is now up a piece and
with Daniel naritzki he also knows the
elephant inside and out so it may be a
dodgy opening in the classical chess
levels but he works super hard he's a
lot of experience so yeah if 92 check
nice Fork there he's taking this game he
is evened up this match
yeah it's all level now and we're back
to where we started okay we have um the
E4 opening from Bolt's neck and uh these
these positions generally should be
quite even
um but the flow is currently
um with white at the moment with
Baltimore and can you keep it up uh as
he goes this is again like a position
where I prefer white I think because
Black's Pawn in the middle could well be
weak later on
and it's gone so he sacrificed it but
for this tactic don't take that Bishop
that is a poison Bishop there would have
been a bishop H2 check and that would
have discovered the Queens against each
other so instead we get into an end game
where white is up a pawn so Simon you're
100 correct we look at the position it's
a clean extra Pawn for board Nick and oh
he takes there and he's just gonna win
another
yeah it's uh two pawns up it is opposite
color Bishops meaning if the Rooks come
off probably a draw but the Rooks aren't
off the Rooks are on the board and um
also whitesbrook is doing a great job of
stopping the black king moving towards
those past pawns so uh very difficult
position of black probably losing now
white is getting ready to support his
Pawn support the advance of that pawn
but he's just improving his pieces as
much as he can first and I think that B
Pawn is going to be a winner here
it's running up the board and as you
said opposite code Bishops often give
drawing chances even down a couple of
Pawns but this is probably lost In
classical chess and it's likely lost in
bullet except for the clock I'm looking
over there and it's paravian who's up
about six seconds and BoRics trying his
best and maybe there's something here
for him oh he can he can sacrifice a
piece because the B Pawn was that good
and he's fighting it back a bit I mean
it's not my oh
as soon as I say that
a The Rook drops and white takes a very
important win there you can see David
laughing on the camera there but he's
probably crying inside there a bit and I
think this Alicorn opening at the moment
like I say you know Bortnick is making
it look pretty good uh Black's positions
are not as bad as I thought they would
be no and this looks like a Scandinavian
all of a sudden so it looks like he
learned from Men playing the scandi
structure a David private beat minlay
yesterday that was an upset and he wants
to land another one in this match
against Bortnick and I feel Bortnick
gaining that confidence he he started
off he lost game one they were going
back and forth then provin won two in a
row but suddenly I I'm sensing Bortnick
recognizing I've got this one
agreed and um he is gaining confidence
his play is getting better and better
and uh you can see in this position if
anyone has the advantage it must be
black because White's piece is on the
queen side they're sleeping you don't
want to have sleeping pieces and that's
why black is now playing for the win not
taking a draw extra space to Black and
look at that open file as well that's a
very big open file and now a pawn to
boots
uh what amazes me Robert is just how
accurate uh these guys in this
competition they they perform uh it's
it's quite phenomenal you know the the
level of their chess is is really
amazing for the time limit it's it's
incredible
mistakes inevitably will happen in
bullet chess but as you're indicating
very high level of play and we see black
upper Pawn can he convert this he should
start pushing that H Pawn get four in a
row Connect Four along the fifth rank
that should be good for black but
unfortunately he's a little bit tied
down over on the queen side because of
this past Pawn situation for white I'm
looking at the clock and now suddenly
parabian is down on time and we know how
lightning fast Bortnick is
yeah I think the clock's gonna be the
key thing on this black is doing well
black has the extra material but it's
eight seconds seven seconds each and who
is going to lose on time it looks like
board Nick has the speed in this one
that is the key thing three seconds now
so fast can he get rid of that Bishop in
time I can't he just and he's just
pre-moving right he's just going around
the board with his Knight it's gonna
just you know be pestering white and he
went with a second to spare it was
really close on time and then the end
Gap one second that may not seem like a
lot but it actually really is in bullet
chess so uh we have to be mesmerized by
these late game speed of Border he'll be
down on the clock early and it's in part
because of his opening repertoire I
think he gets some shaky positions but
the way he's able to weasel his way out
in any time scramble I mean it's such
really high level stuff
yes agreed and I think he's found the
right opening as well to play this seems
to be giving him his white much better
positions than the Jabar for London was
and you mentioned it Robert that ability
to adapt and I think it's a real skill
in chess you could say in life as well
you know you you learn skills in chess
that you take over to life
um like running around like you're
playing bullet chess nope that's that's
not always the case but adapting and uh
I like what he's doing here look at the
queen and the bishop okay but Black's
managed to get the Queens off now that's
really helped Black's structure a lot
and what's going on here it's an even
material end game but Black's Pawn is in
White's camp and White's Pawn is in
Black's camp and I think white is better
just because the E4 Pawn sticks out it's
uh it's overextended and he's taken oh
he goes back now that is classy he
didn't want to allow the black Rook to
get active so he just walks his King
back and says your e-pawn's going
nowhere
yeah very clever move one of the most
important things to remember in Rook
endings is the activity of your Rooks
and um whoa can you can you play horn on
what a tactic that is look at that the
black porn suddenly becoming a queen and
that is very painful for David there
another potential loss here
well I mean David I think actually is
the happy one right now he's getting it
with the black piece
based on what we've been seeing in
recent games it seemed like it was all
Bortnick but suddenly paravin is the one
in charge and he needed this game so
badly and he is taking it he's up on
time he's up a queen and as long as he
doesn't blunder all his pieces it's a
win for black yeah and with the time as
well he should be just putting this in
the bag now uh my mistake there
important win for David it goes so quick
I sometimes lose track of who's playing
it's you know it's the speed it is but I
think the Gap is only one point now
um with nine minutes to go uh and they
have to win by two points as well right
to to to go through
they do so a one point deficit that's
not the worst thing in the world for
Providence but it's not good to drop
your D4 opponent I have to say that
sometimes you do it you get an
initiative but usually you don't like to
trade Queens in the process
yeah it's it's all okay to sacrifice but
uh you you've got to get enough
compensation and generally when you
sacrifice as you mentioned you want to
keep the Queens on the ball but this has
maybe given him something uh two Bishops
the black king not entirely healthy okay
it has now Castle but with two Bishops
on the board you're always in these kind
of positions where there's open lines
gonna have compensation and um I might
even prefer white here
um a bit easier for white to play Bishop
C7 is coming he could have taken on d8
and Bishop C7 he says again if he trades
Rooks and plays this bishop Bishop C7
doesn't work now because the Knight
protects the other night but he had it
and I was waiting for it I was like
holding my tongue being like watch out
for that idea and it's sometimes you're
in the flow you're just you're coming up
with moves you trust your opponent but
we do have the evil bar off to the side
that helps us in addition to coming up
with some of the Tactical shots that you
know if they don't work who cares we can
take the move back but the players uh it
might be their last chance
yeah and he just played it one move too
late there didn't it in in the position
it's still I think quite dangerous black
uh because this Pawn on the side of the
board and look at that pawn go the
knights are kind of dominating the
bishop so and that Knight getting over
but five seconds up on the clock four
white as well
how do we rate this ending frog are you
ready for white but five seconds a lead
I don't think is enough for probably
just the speed that boarding plays and
look at this the advantage is going up
and down back to the middle they're both
queening here oh and that was a blunder
that will end the game right there
yeah
do we have a level I think we have level
score now maybe uh we do I make it and
you can see botnik very upset with that
one this is really really tense and um
the reward if you win this loses bracket
is that you get to play against Daniel
and uh I don't know what kind of reward
that is it sounds quite scary
but it's going to be tough for these
players today because they want to stay
and they have to win two matches right
two matches in a row
and you know that's sounds more like a
punishment to me I don't want to be
playing Donya in bullet he's too strong
uh but both of these players on a good
day they can take down pretty much
anyone in this competition okay Hikaru
Magnus farouza they're always going to
be difficult to beat but uh Bortnick and
Donna have played each other so many
times and in this game uh Bortnick seems
to have the upper hand he's going for
checkmate the side with the safer King
usually is doing well in bullet chess
the King on G1 it's tucked at home this
King on G8 there's a lot of weak squares
in front of it but that apparently
oh Knight takes E4 wow wow what a tactic
there
spotting the move very quickly but I
still actually oh he's playing so good
such good defensive chess I was going to
say I'm actually preferring white
because the Knight and queen are very
dangerous but I love what black has done
with the dark Square Bishop because that
dark Square Bishop can get rid of that
Knight very tense position here though
yeah just don't move your knight on F6
because then Queen H7 is mate but now
you could take on G5 and take this
bishop on F7 that's exactly what
paravian I thought was going for but he
brings his Knight to E4 so what is
happening the white Bishop escapes
steals this G6 Pawn but suddenly black
is winning according to the evaluation
bar
wow some amazing tactics
that was Queenie one just about keeps in
the game but he picks up a piece there
incredible tactics
black doing very well on the clock and
on the board and this is gonna I think
and it does give black the lead in the
match could this be an upset in the
making David taking the lead I think one
of the well certainly at this point with
five minutes ago
very critical uh botnik needs to needs
to Crunch back now
if my numbers are correct uh pravin went
two in a row Bortnick then bounced back
with four straight wins and now paravian
has taken three games in a row so
they're going on streaks bullet often is
a match of streaks and we see in this
game that uh bornik he's back to his
alicon he's getting active with the
queen bouncing around the board and well
it looks like a fine opening it hasn't
gone badly but the clock situation
paravian is over 15 seconds ahead and
Bortnick as we've seen is super fast but
he can't afford to be down this much
time
no time is so so important there's
probably some formula out there at this
level which uh gives you a pawn is worth
like five seconds or 10 seconds and what
is this move he's gone for a crazy
sacrifice there that doesn't look
entirely sound but we've mentioned this
time and time again the side who is
attacking often gets the win because
attacking is so important at this speed
limit but
black has back rank threats as well here
Robert
Queen D1 right now he almost pre-moved
that and there's not there's one check
on C4 but Rook D5 the Knight defends it
and that blocks the CH that was amazing
vision from Bortnick
brilliant defense there I I would never
have seen that myself and uh black is
now serious material up uh he's got 12
seconds it's probably enough uh for
these two at this speed limit and look
at that a beautiful back rank finish to
win the game and that levels the score
again they are neck and neck what a
match to get us started uh you cannot
you cannot tell you know
tell the difference between these guys
at the moment right
we're completely spoiled this match has
been stellar and it's three minutes plus
to go so if somebody can win this game
and win the one that follows they may
win the matching regulation but it seems
based on the back and forth nature of it
that extra time is likely and apparently
there's a blunder I think there was
Bishop takes F6 there a pretty
Elementary tactic if they had more time
to sit and calculate but you have to be
very careful here and not to blunder
something because you only have one game
after this to make up the deficit oh
I love what Black's done with the
Knights there but maybe that last night
move was a little bit too much and very
aggressive play from black but you open
up your own King as well whose King is
weaker again this important idea maybe
Black's getting ready to sacrifice in
the middle that could be interesting and
he does he sacrifices for what he hopes
his initiative but look at the black
king the black king is actually now
proving to be I think the weaker one
maybe just Rook takes Knight the black
king it's in so much trouble here
although you know good on paravian to
make this only a one Pawn deficit he
encouraged and exchange sacrifice in
return so it is better for white right
now it's about seven second lead for
paravian but we keep seeing that
Bortnick he's down on time and then he
just pre-moves everything in the
scramble so King F3 I guess the Queens
are being traded but that was not on my
radar
yeah it's a hard move to play When the
Queens are still on the board but white
is trying to get ready for the ending
and there's good chances that white can
get the win here get the Rook active
take some more pawns
um
uh is any drawing chances of black well
it's a lot of Pawns here this should be
a white win keep an eye on the clock
though it's going to be an important
factor
that's exactly why I think morning is
going to win this game I'm looking at it
he is just pre-moving left and right
every move seems to be pretty strong
private actually taking the lead in The
Clock maybe I'm underestimating how
quick paravian is but there's a queen is
landed in two seconds is he have enough
time
oh oh he's barely gonna move up point
five I think 0.3 seconds left for
Bortnick wow
what a win that was taking the lead and
this is a massive game if black wins
this game it's very likely that bodnick
will be playing against Daniel in the
next round so it is so important that
white just doesn't lose here and it yeah
this is this is the the key game
yes and Bortnick down a few seconds in
the opening that is par for the course
in this matchup the Knight on E5 is a
problem he's throwing his pawns forward
like he's been wanting to do and I have
to say I really like White's position
I like what white is doing going for the
attack G5 brilliant move uh the black
king looking well very exposed here uh
with the White Queen about to jump in so
uh botmakers trying to sacrifice to take
some of that pressure off his King maybe
a good practical decision
um and I love that move as well F5 what
a brilliant move Robert trying to open
up the black king even more getting
ready for the bishop the only Bishop on
the board to fly in and this is looking
good for white but he must he must get a
result here if somehow things go wrong
he's out
yeah if he loses this game he's out of
the competition that would be David
Robin but right now he's up a piece he's
going for checkmate but he gives away
the D4 Pawn that's not mate
yeah I mean it looks very scary this
position for black but black is now
equal on material white would love to
get the Rook to check the black king but
the white Rook has always blocked here
good maneuver there though that was oh
no sir would be really clever yeah
and he missed it you can't miss Forks
like that but he has a second chance
oh my goodness if there's a Checkmate
maybe this was really clever stuff but
he walked into a fork himself
unbelievable
and he proves at my time he's got to
move Brown's gonna move why is he Frozen
oh no
unbelievable this
and Peruvian he is slightly no he's
using his time a little bit too much he
needs to move more quickly he's losing
our time
he's only got a second left he's got to
move quickly he's got a pre-move and he
fell for that trick and he's out and he
loses and we have a winner Bortnick has
gone through in a game that he should
have lost white oh there's another game
is there another game no I think that
they're just so used to pressing the
rematch button but Bortnick the person
you see on the screen in front of you he
moves through to face Daniel narodisky
what a game that was it should have been
paravian's game he had a lead on the
clock he was up a piece for some pawns
but Bortnick he just does it so often he
comes back he stares defeat in the face
and he steals Victory from the jaws of
defeat so Bortnick moves on that was in
pretty close match I mean that went down
to the wire but when all is said and
done bornick proves why he's so highly
rated on chess.com Simon for paravian
though
yeah I mean that that really didn't
deserve a loser uh that match I mean
they were both neck and neck and that
last game the pressure got a little bit
too much for David Darren and he missed
this night Fork he could have just won
the rook and won the game bringing it to
a tie break situation but I think the
fighting Spirit from Bortnick that was
uh what won him that match and also it
won him an extra two thousand dollars uh
66 dollars a minute we worked out Robert
all you worked out should I say so uh uh
good work there well great work from
Bortnick that was so close it went down
to the final game but he wins it doesn't
matter how he got it done just that he
did so he gets the play Daniel nerdinski
a bit later today in the losers quarter
final so Bortnick moves on unfortunately
from paravian that's the last we'll see
from him in the 2023 bullet Chess
Championship but we have so many great
matches ahead Andrew Tang against Jose
Martinez will be the next match we cover
but first we're gonna head to a break
because when return we'll bring them in
you just saw deliver Victory oh it's
under Bortnick we'll interview him we'll
hear his thoughts and I certainly can't
wait to hear how he feels after that
fantastic match stay tuned everybody
we'll be right back
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest puzzles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
oh
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
thank you
we are glad to be joined by the winner
of that very tight match Alexander
Bortnick Sasha congratulations on what
was an awesome match to watch how are
you feeling are you finally you know
able to breathe a little bit
hi Chad thank you so much
oh that was actually a very tough match
uh he was extremely fast and and we're
just playing you know the some bullet
games and I watched my clock I'm done
like 15 seconds every game every single
game I just was behind him on time
and I didn't recognize uh that was final
game actually and we played I thought
it's more like two or three games more I
even didn't see what the score is it was
really fast in the end and hopefully I
won
I won the last last game
yeah it seemed like a very exciting
match it was uh it was very close uh you
seemed super focused there and uh we
were talking about your openings a bit
and the use of the alacoin as black and
we'll see the Jabar for London we saw
you switch the Jabar for London out
there and do you play the same openings
in bullet that you play In classical
chess generally
no absolutely different I'm playing I'm
not using the lakhan or jababa London
because against 2600 when you play him
that's that's not not the best opening
choice for the classic but in blizzes
always work like you could see
so probably one more game is black than
white I guess and uh why why I switched
the opening because I just forget my own
course so this like like always when
you're working a lot you'll just forget
in the line and I remember that's good
position for white what that line he
used but I don't remember the move and
in bullet we don't have a time you know
recognize exactly what's the move and
after the first game when I Got the
Blues in position from the low pressure
okay you need to change my opening for
sure
I just I've just had something there I I
know exactly the feeling when you make a
course and you forget about it I've I've
had the same problem with the jabala
London as well it's an easy place
oh look at this Simon you've been an
influence for uh Versace here
well it depends if you liked it or not
all right thanks for reading it anyway
so uh but yeah very very exciting match
though
yeah and uh Sasha a question I have for
you is you start out by each winning a
game with black it would you know he
want you one he won you won and then he
won two in a row and then you want four
in a row and then he won several in a
row how does that feel like the roller
coaster of a bullet match where you're
trading off win streaks does that ever
get you nervous or do you just think
it's part of the game
um yeah of course we are nervous so much
um I remember I just lost like two games
in the robots of the winning positions
and I already started to make a little
tilt because come on I was asleep like
already plus two and then you just
emulate yourself because that that's a
problem actually you have to be calm uh
during the old match when you just come
like for example Hikaru he just uh every
single game like first game he even if
he lose him he can like start
nothing happened let's keep going just
and that's
actually very good
um
I don't know I need to learn that too
because I have some problems with my
tilt so but hopefully finish good
it's easy to get emotional when the you
you'll win though in that game you you
probably know who you're playing next
and you're playing Tanya next and uh I
know that both of you have made this
great course on the Jabar for London I'm
hoping we're going to see one or two
Jabara London's in in that match uh but
what are your feelings about
um facing your friend Dania
I will try to avoid actually to power
London for sure okay
um
um you know yeah this is hard always to
play against your friends uh especially
when you work a lot with that guy and he
knows your weaknesses he knows your
strong size and but you know I I will
not be so upset if I will lose because
one of us will go to the next stage so
we'll see I will try of course to find
my best and Friends chess chess doesn't
have friends you know
yeah and when we played in the boards
that's that that's no friends there
yeah so definitely will be South
Jordan's flags from him okay he's really
fast so Rook against Rock
yeah we'll see
well I mean Sasha sounds like you're a
good friend that you know no matter who
wins you're gonna be happy uh but you're
also a prolific streamer so I want to
give you a shout out for that uh do you
feel like you know Hikaru often says
that streaming his fans that give him
confidence I know you're not streaming
at this moment but have you felt that
along the way because ever since 2019 in
the bullet Chess Championship when you
made to the finals it seems like you've
just been an online star in all these
tournaments
yeah
um I'm not streaming because I think
it's maybe it will help actually in the
bullet you are more concentrated focused
because people just watching you in the
chat and you just don't wanna
don't wanna no need to just find a word
what
um
don't wanna looks bad you know like
um so maybe I had maybe I should
actually stream too but when we start I
didn't know we had we could use the
headphones actually and it's only on for
in the second day because I like to
record the music and listen to music
when I'm playing
so
yeah let's see my last question you know
I'll let you prepare for Daniel my last
question is what music do you listen to
when you're playing
absolutely different absolutely
different it's uh I in my playlist I
have some rocks I have some uh deep
house even some classic music so it's
I don't know I I can listen just I have
to like the music the the music and sit
and have some special guys
well we'll let you listen to them some
music prepare because we know you have
another match coming up shortly but
thanks so much Sasha congratulations on
what was a fantastic match win
thank you so much guys thank you
and that is Grandmaster Alexander
Bortnick he beats David paravian in a
really close matchup in losers record
round three he moves on to face his good
friend as somebody he works with Daniel
nariditsky but before we get to that
match we have Andrew Tang against Jose
Martinez better known as Jasper coming
up that should be another exciting
bullet matchup because Jasper qualified
his way here Andrew Tang was invited and
yesterday looked like the penguin GM
that everybody out there knows and loves
so it depends on what form each player
is in and if the first match is any
indication we should have another barn
burner of a match coming up
yeah 100 I I think they're all going to
be very close today I've just got that
feeling uh that we're gonna see lots of
the games come down to the wire and uh
the other reward uh that is going to be
offered in that match to the winner not
just an extra two thousand dollars which
is a tremendous amount for half an hour
of Chess but the winner of that match
gets to play against Magnus Carlson and
I know all these players really want to
play Magnus because he is a legend you
get a chance to play a legend and uh
that's a really cool prize right Robin
playing Magnus I think everyone loves
they relish the opportunity to play
Magnus and Andrew Tang is somebody who
is very familiar with magnus's game
because they have played countless games
uh over the years in all type patrols
especially you know hyper bullet and all
that stuff but he is a two-time bullet
Chess Championship runner-up now he is
prolific in content creation on YouTube
he streams on Twitch as well he's a
recent graduate of Princeton University
he talked about his trips with his
friends but right now he is going to sit
in that chair and play bullet for 30
minutes because he is a tough opponent
in front of him in Jose Martinez
yeah it's uh it's gonna be a very close
match and we we know how strong both of
these players are uh how quick they both
can be and um I I I who are you gonna
pick Robert I mean I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go for Andrew I'll put my neck on
the line there but I also have a feeling
this is gonna go to tie breaks
okay so Simon calls for a tie breaks and
well the person who may help determine
that is Jose Martinez because we know
what Tang can do when he's at his best
and that is often but at his best at his
Peak Jose Martinez has been over 3 200
in bullet on chess.com he won the under
18 World Championship that is a huge
accomplishment for any player and he won
the first qualifier uh he beat suleimani
The azeri Grandmaster he beat I mean
Ohanian who we saw earlier in this
competition a beat Anish giri I mean in
an international master from Armenia and
there is Jose he's from Peru but lives
in Mexico and he looks cool in that
jacket
yeah he does and uh I I would not be
surprised at all if Jose was you know
wins the match he's a very very strong
player yeah he's very good Under
Pressure he's proven that in previous
matches and as you mentioned he plays a
lot on chess.com he's a bit of a legend
on chess.com uh everyone knows Jose and
um this this is going to be another
exciting one but just to remind people
they are playing for a chance to face
Magnus they're playing for an extra two
thousand dollars and the loser is also
knocked out so how much more can you put
on the line uh than those uh those big
things there that's enough I think here
don't put any more pressure on them yeah
you know their pressure is on themselves
they just want to win that's what
they're aiming for uh the money they'll
deal with it after fact oh I could have
won 2 000 more dollars but right now
they want to move on here in the BCC to
play Magnus Carlsen I don't even think
that's on their mind because if you're
playing Jose or if you're Jose playing
Andrew that's already big enough
challenge you don't need to think about
the world number one that's in the
future and you may never get there so
Andrew's the favorite you said it it's
just true he is the higher rated player
he is a wealth of experience he goes Toe
to Toe with the best players on the
planet but it depends on which Andrew
shows up and I really mean that the
Andrew that showed up against Dania I
don't think that will necessarily get it
done against Jose but the Andrew we saw
yesterday uh and in the first match up
when he beat on draken that Andrew Tang
is scary
100 and we'll find out very very shortly
uh which Andrew is going to be playing
and uh if if you're wondering in the
chat Magnus will be playing later on so
don't worry about that the best player
in the world is due to be playing the
winner of this match and off and very
sharp opening uh already
and is this some kind of theory that I
don't know about because they've made
all their bunch of moves in five seconds
each before tank paused and brought his
King up to F2 I like Black's position we
keep saying it the side with the safer
King is usually the happy side in bullet
and black is a safer King and is up a
pawn
uh yeah a great uh black has extra Pawn
the king is on F2 it is only one Pawn
it's not a winning uh enough a material
advantage at this time limit it's more
to do with the pieces and Andrew does
seem to be unraveling his position a
little bit that night grabbing a nice
square but this bishop doesn't have
anywhere good to go okay it dives into
Black's position there yeah so it's all
the way in bless Camp the A5 Pawn is
loose and Jose says go take my queen
side pawns I'm going after your king I
want Checkmate and here go now white is
up a pawn but Black's pawns are storming
up the king side
they are and there they go again up the
board and it does seem like black has
some initiative here remember that is
the most important thing at this time
limit get the pressure that Rook gaining
a lovely Square in the center Andrew's
got to do some defending if Andrew can
defend this he will convert his extra
pawn and there it goes that extra Pawn
but black is now threatening Checkmate
and it's midjust defending in time he
missed me if he started with Queen H2
Jack and then played Bishop A6 black
would have won the game so he took too
many steps before acting and that it's
going to cost him as now suddenly it is
white with the attack and the extra
material
very good spot there Robert I didn't see
that and uh you're completely right he
set up the check maybe he could have
checkmated straight away and now the
game has totally turned around but Rook
G2 what was that with was that a mouse
slip I feel that was a mouse lip at the
time I I I didn't ever even have a
chance to look at the clock there Robert
I don't know how the players managed to
look at the clock and the board at the
same time I can't as a commentator
that's why I made the move Rook G2 he
stopped any sort of Checkmate that would
happen on that diagonal and it took Jose
some time to figure out you know wait is
that piece just hanging and he grabbed
it so I think Andrew he just showcased
his speed that was a really nice uh
effort at the End by him but Jose had a
winning position I mean Jose is going to
regret not taking that first game
yeah every point is going to be critical
in this one and moving on to the next
game white does have an extra pawn and
it looks like white has the better
attacking chances here look at White's
light Square Bishop this is a key piece
and the queen threatening some big check
there black has to weaken his King even
more and now the White Knight has some
holes it can move into at the right
moment can that knight move in now it
looks very tempting he's just pushing
the H Pawn here very interesting
position but he's just Blended something
on the back rank it would appear but no
that was not right maybe there's a
simple Rook D1 instead of Rook c h it's
so tempting to give a check but there
was pin action along the default he's
going for a mate Knight F6 Rook G8 we
see what's trying to happen and oh he
walks right into it apparently because
Rook F1 check for black apparently
that's just one check and you don't have
a follow-up
we will find out here The Rook surely
can check now I mean there's still looks
dangerous but you have Queen takes C1 so
if the the root checks the king comes
here this is the first time I've ever
tried doing Arrow so The Rook checks
there the queen can take it look at that
Robert I actually use the arrow button
are you impressed I'm very impressed I'm
proud of you in fact and I think uh well
we should be proud of Jose as well
because he's rebounded from game one and
they're I don't see any safe checks for
black anymore and that's why Andrew
resigns
yeah that was actually a pretty nice
finish and a very very complicated
position and they're back on straight
away with the next game and they're
following the same opening as before but
this ended up being very good for black
here and maybe this is uh Knight D3 I
think is the Improvement I'm getting a
bit carried away with these uh arrows
now and why I like White's position he's
got a lovely hold of that square that
his Knights on and he's also pushing on
the king side yeah no this uh looks
suddenly like white is definitely in
charge that's like oh a protected pass
Pawn on the sixth ring that is not good
news for Jose and well he's been able to
stabilize a bit somehow
this King on G2 also not the safest
piece with a rook coming to G8 so he
goes for that right here and that King
on H3 actually is oh queen of five he
blundered this Pawn I was supposed to
say that Rook was tied down and now
Bishop D6 follows with checkmate
massive blunder there and all of a
sudden the white King was the major
Target and Jose taking the lead and
um someone mentioning that they didn't
see my arrows a bit disappointed about
that I I'm sure I didn't make them up
and maybe I did maybe I just had them in
my mind I might try them again at some
point but it's very it's very quick for
hours and here we go black winning a
pawn immediately in this game yes and
that's a pretty important Pawn right in
front of the white king side and well
now that the position is where we're at
the extra Pawn is on E6 so it's not
gonna help making a pass pawn and that
means it's maybe not the biggest deal in
the world and this bishop on G7 doesn't
really have any Targets to work against
no I mean I don't think this position is
that bad at all for white and look at
that night Robert that Knight has a
juicy Square in the middle of the board
I mean you know that night is as good as
any piece any piece on the board and in
actual fact I I think I'd prefer white
here the extra Pawn is irrelevant and
who's got the easier playing that Rook
can come in with a big check all the
whites Pieces Just dominating here but
when that King was on D6 he missed
Knight takes B6 the C Pawn was pinned it
was so tempting to bring your Rook into
the game and now that his Rook has won
the H7 Pawn you can hardly blame him it
just seems like Jose is taking
everything right now all right where's
the B5 Pawn
oh you know what happened there Simon he
expected Knight E8 check which would
have protected The Rook so he pre-moved
King back over to E6 that's why it is so
important not to be down on the clock in
bullet you then you won't don't have to
pre-move
yeah I mean it's one of those situations
where uh what can you do you know uh you
have to pre-move occasionally and Here
Andrew loses another game with uh just
missing that opportunity there by
pre-moving and he goes two points uh
down uh in in the match and we're
getting the same opening again I think
white seems to be doing all right from
here but black gets lots of chances to
open up the middle that's why black
continues to uh uh Play This Way yeah
this whoa Bishop takes E4 and he doesn't
even take the piece because after Knight
takes E4 maybe there were some
complications he said I'm just gonna
open up the center and this looks great
for what if you take on B6 the pawn
takes back that is another healthy past
Pawn so he gives up the exchange instead
but this is clearly good for Andrew tank
yes
um got the the Brooks that look very
good Brooks work really well on open
lines and both of the white Rooks are on
open lines there's an extra white Rook
um so white should be getting one point
back here this is a game I think Andrew
must win he doesn't want to go three
points down in this match uh if he wins
this over only be one point down with
plenty of time to go so
um Jose's gotta keep trying
Andrew's just got a
keep his head
in a sensible place here and maybe get
the Queens off there he could have gone
Queen in
I'd be wanting to get the Queens off if
I was white
yeah I'm with you oh that's why that's
why I kept the Queens on because he was
waiting for a tactical shot and that's
resignation from Jose that means three
to two lead for Martina still so Jasper
that's it was a rough one for him but
for tank he needs another Victory to
even up the score
yes we saw this opening before where
black did manage to get a tactic against
the pawn on H3 so it seemed to work out
opening eyes quite well for black but
they're very uh sort of equal position
in the middle here uh Black's double
pause could be a strength and there goes
a pawn uh I think Jose just blundered
that pawn but it's not so clear because
white wins a pawn back in the middle
there
yeah Jose has blundered a night Pawn in
consecutive games with the white PC
blunder the G Pawn Knight London is the
B Pawn and he's trying to bring his
Knight into the game but that D5 Pawn
it's isolated up there so it seems that
oh nice move Knight C3 this D5 Pawn is a
goner and that should leave black much
much better up material
I like what White's done though rather
than trying to hold on to the pawn he
jettison's The Exchange and it's all
about trying to remain as active as you
can and the white Knights are a little
bit tricky here black should of course
be winning this position but you've got
to watch out for the knights and I like
what Blackstone closing it down in the
middle
but Jose creating idea after ideas and
look at that he gets the trick in
oh what a fight from Jose there I
actually did not like Andrew's decision
to play C5 and allow white this Pawn on
D6 but it seems like the B Pawn that's
the strongest piece on the board that's
the strongest Pawn that one's running to
the other side
it is and it has touched down and become
a queen and this means that Andrew
should certainly be leveling the score
now he's just going to stop those pawns
great technique there give up a root for
one of the pawns and it's now all even
the matches are just so close today they
could not get closer it's what happens
when you have these superstars of the
bullet Chess World and this opening that
we keep seeing I've never seen it before
so I am actually receiving a lesson
thank you to both of the players I I
don't really like this position for
black I liked it in the first game
because white went wrong but I love this
position for Andrew the C file is
semi-open and that's good news for the
rook and the King after especially for
G5 that King is exposed
I agree with you Robert I think in
bullet chess you might be able to get
away with just kind of opening as black
but
um positionally uh it should only be
white who's better uh but again Jose
creating chances he's a very brave
player this is what I like about Jose he
will grab a pawn even if it looks scary
and he's grabbed those pawns there and
now he's able to swap the Queen's off
but white getting active with the Rooks
this could go either way
um very tense situation remember whoever
wins this one takes the lead in the
match well how many pass pawns does
somebody need black has two of them and
a third of the eight part of and get
running but I like what you said there
because I didn't even see that A2 Pawn
was hanging when Jose took it but he has
this full board awareness and that
bravery that courage to steal upon and
then bring his Queen back and now he has
all of these passers he is down a couple
seconds that might in the back of his
head worry him and suddenly this King on
h8 it's not very safe anymore
I love what Andrew did there I mean he
he had a very bad position but he kind
of tricked Jose and this is now the
Seesaw I love the Seesaw and look at
that seesawing its way to Victory
there's a Checkmate coming in the corner
brilliant bullet play from Andrew there
he he shouldn't have been able to defend
against those pawns but he tricked Jose
in a in a very nice Style
what a game that was topsy-turvy uh Jose
probably quite upset because he was
leading this match by two games now he
is trailing uh by one after Andrew's
latest Victory and what is this some
kind of uh temporary peace sacrifice
they're really showing me openings that
I know nothing about so I'm appreciative
of these players
yeah I mean they're both um yeah this
this four nights we're seeing quite a
lot and they're they don't understand of
it is quite phenomenal they seem to be
getting very equal positions out of the
opening uh but Jose is a bit of a
dangerous situation here because I feel
he's worse here the two Bishops look
good blacks majority of Pawns on the
king side also look strong and um if
Jose loses this one he's lost I think
it's is it three or four in a row and
that's when it starts to get really bad
because Andrew will grow in confidence
and grow on the scoreboard as well so
what is happening here uh is white
fighting back I think Jose's fighting
very hard here doing a great job yeah it
looked like a sicilian all of a sudden
and now it looks like great night
against not so great Bishop on f8 and
that move Rook D4 he's allowing Bishop
G7 but he's got wasn't there Knight A7
over there that was a fork
oh wow well spotted Knight A7 would have
won material uh that would have been a
great move this position is still very
unclear black has the extra exchange but
I love the White Knight and to my eyes
the white king looks to be a lot safer
so can the White Knight and queen get in
he's going for a beautiful idea wow and
Rook D7 no throwing Rook D7 he get Rook
takes D7 check first and he would have
been up a queen for a rook instead we
have two Rooks against a queen that was
a huge mistake from Jose and look at the
clock though he actually has it on time
I didn't look that way it's so hard to
keep up with these players
it is and again you know you just don't
have time to look at everything surely I
don't know how they do it I've said it
before but Jose wins a very important
game there in a position where uh it
wasn't so great and it's equal again
they have 16 minutes to go
four out of four this match is knotted
up once again and oh look at this
position I mean white just has the
advantage very clearly you have so much
more space is that really a bishop on H7
it's not doing much of anything and here
comes the pawn storm
yeah the pawn storm of the king side
looks much more scary to Black's credit
black has created some counter play on
The Queen side you look at White's Pawn
on B3 by the bishop maybe that could be
taken quite risky taking it because you
could walk into a pin Jose's trying to
work out if he can or not but white
striking first for that G5 move and I
think you can take with either piece
with taking the bishop seems smart to me
the F5 Pawn that's the only Square where
black can put pressure on and F6 is
hanging H7 saying is King G7 the only
he gives up the house
okay so what's happening here I mean uh
the black king seems to be in serious
trouble can you get the rook in this
move look natural but the evaluation bar
does not like it white goes a rook up
but is the black queen getting enough
checks
apparently there was something there
that allowed black to survive I'm not
going to pretend like I could see that
there's probably one and one move only
that allowed black to keep the balance
but now we're here where the white king
is looking very safe all of White's
pieces are surrounding it and okay there
are no more attackers to work with so
Jose resigns
and Andrew takes the one point lead
um and here actually you know this
opening I'd be I would have been very
tempted after G6 to have taken on E5
that could have been a very interesting
uh opening idea but we don't really have
enough time to go into deep opening
analysis I feel Robert in in this uh
bullet bullet competition
no and unfortunately not you know I'm
trying to learn but they're moving so
quickly that I can barely see okay that
move was played okay that move was
played and here we see uh pawns are
going up the board for Jose he likes his
part storms and it's Connect Four he won
okay he made he made the connection
first definitely uh black does get his
Knight to a nice Square though it's
always a bit dangerous the white king
with a black knight hovering around it
like that and I like what Andrew's done
creating counterplay another good move
from Andrew he's ready to strike on the
king side White's completely dominating
on the other side of the board but
King side attacks are much more
dangerous than Queen side attacks
because the king is over there and if
you break through it will be Checkmate
my head has been on a swivel looking at
the Queen's Day look at the Kingston
look at the queens of the king side and
the eval bar is now see-song back down
apparently Queen takes F3 was better but
that might have included a queen
sacrifice with the Rooks looking down
the f file but this still looks unclear
to me I see the eval bar is saying that
black is much better but it's a
situation where the black king is okay
well that gives up and exchange it he
doesn't even capture it
is changing so quickly now it's the
white knight which seems dominating and
white piece is suddenly creeping into
the position uh it has been about the
power of the night today in these
matches
um and this could go either way uh this
one this could be a key turning point in
the match let's remember Andrew is one
point up and it seems like he's gonna
win this one and go two points up
big game for him I think Jose pre-moved
Rook F5 not considering Queen back to F7
to block the check so Jose was trying to
pick up the pace but unfortunately for
him he didn't was not able to see
everything that was happening over the
board and when you're pre-moving that
often happens so it's a win for Andrew
now with the white pieces it seems like
he is a very solid Center and that C4
Pawn is overextended and now the black
king also feels vulnerable
yeah I really didn't like G5 move that
black played because we're talking about
King safety how important it is in
bullet chess and you only want to expose
your King by pushing the Pawns in front
of your king if there's a good reason to
do so a bit like classical chess uh your
king you have to be very careful uh
about its security and the white piece
is now starting to encroach upon the
black King's position and uh if Andrew
wins this one again that the lead is
growing and growing it could be three
points The Rook swings over black can't
survive there surely Robert no way
especially after that cruncher in King
takes us the next Rook swinging H1
delivering a Checkmate or winning all
the pieces so that was another win for
Andrew Tang they're still 11 and a half
minutes remaining in this matter there
is time for Jose to catch up but just
the way those last bunch of games have
gone it seems like Jose is bordering on
tilting
yes it does seem a bit uh that way and
uh again uh the flow is with Andrew I
think we've seen what Andrew's turned up
though today Robert is is it's the
dangerous one and a dangerous Andrew is
capable of beating anyone the winner of
this match will play Magnus as well how
many times you think uh uh Andrew has
played against Magnus and bullet chess
that's an interesting fact where stat
will have to find out later on I would
say too many for their own good but I
don't think anyone can say what's good
for Magnus chess he knows what's best
for it he has been the highest rated
player in chess history so yeah I'm not
going to question what they do it's been
good for them both and this position
looks good for white because the King on
G7 looks vulnerable and now we've the
board cut in half where white has an
extra Pawn the king side black is an
extra Pawn on the queen side but white
king is very safe and oh that looks like
there's an option and oh F5 is a great
move
fantastic move just opening up the black
king and you hit the nail on the head
there Robert just pointing out the black
king has no protection and uh you need
to have protection and that King it
needs to have a bishop around it and
White's just opening it up there and
maybe the queen can even come in Queen
takes H5 look very strong there but this
is also a very good move
Jose learned bring all okay was that
another pre-move because he was up a
rook if he didn't go Knight out of five
so there have been these moments where
maybe Jose's premium a bit but Andrew is
no time so he probably was thinking if I
don't win by Checkmate I'll win on the
clock he wins with 15 extra seconds so
Andrew has been down on the clock in
quite a number of games so that I think
is what Jose can rely on as we reach
nine and a half minutes remaining in the
match
yep two points in it at the moment as
well so there's still time nine minutes
is a lot of time one of these matches
um and they're playing quite a solid
position here this is the kind of
position I think Jose plays really well
you know just maneuvering his pieces
kind of waiting for the opponent and I I
would say that's kind of Jose's style
he's like a Viper he just sort of Waits
there and he will just strike as soon as
he gets the opportunity so you can see
the black pieces in this Hedgehog
formation there they look passive but
they wait for their opportunity and
there you go just repeating the position
again yeah Jose and the pressure's not
on him to win this game he's the black
pieces so even though it's bullet chess
some of those mantras still exist in D5
that's one of those critical moves can
you get away with it and if you play too
early it regularly backfires but that's
why Jose he's just hopping around with
his Knights he's up five seconds he's
playing really quickly and very
accurately
he is yeah and they're both just sort of
dancing around here seeing if there's an
opportunity the problem with these kind
of positions is often if you're the
first person to push a pawn you just
make your position worse so you kind of
want to try to do as much as you can
with your pieces and here you go Jose
strikes is it that viper strike there in
the middle he opens up that Bishop in
the corner of the board look at that
Bishop Robert the light Square Bishop
brilliant play from Jose in this game
this has just been a stellar game no
matter the time control and Andrew
sacrifice the piece because his position
was already in in grave danger but
there's no attack look at every move
Jose has played he keeps a six second
lead on the clock and this has been just
maybe the best game of the match from
start to finish
yeah I agree yeah it's been very very
good quality and Black's kept is cool uh
his time should be enough here we know
how dangerous Andrew can be but
should be a win for blackened it will be
just one point in it there Checkmate on
the board
that was seriously impressive that whole
game was a spectacle and now it's a one
point match of the good news for Andrew
is he still has the lead the bad news is
Jose is the one with the confidence two
wins in a row and that very nicely
played game and we get a position where
okay I I wouldn't say there's much of an
advantage for white but now we see
actually a bunch of Trades and it got
tactical out of nowhere
yes and we see an ending now where white
has this porn but Black's Rooks are very
active here and um black should just
about have enough in a critical moment
but okay actually that porn scary scary
is anything I saw a couple of people in
the chat and hello to the chat asking
what was next and we're still in the
losers bracket but
um we go up to I think it's I think it's
right it's the quarterfinals or the
semi-finals the next round anyway just
as I'm not sure
yeah it's the quarterfinals yeah so
board nickel played Dania and then the
winner of this match will play Magnus
and for a long time at least for the
last stretch it felt like it was gonna
be Tang who was gonna move on but
suddenly in this end game oh the
advantage was really high in White's
favor and now it's back to draw's
territory and he doesn't have enough
time look at Tang ahead in the clock
it's a change of pace for him and now
he's winning
wow wow King important endings you you
would have thought they're quite easy
but in actual fact they are so so
complex and I would recommend to anyone
if you want to improve your calculation
start with King and pawn endings it's
the purest kind of calculation you can
get and this
should be a draw but black has a bit of
a time of artists so you might as well
try and win here with the black pieces
yeah it's one of these situations
whereas white and I can block with check
and then he trades off the Queens but
it's like you know it's a drawer come on
just give me the draw like no I'm gonna
try to flag you and Andrew is not
accepting the draw yet he's wasting some
of the match clock I wonder what his
strategy is
well he still keeps the one point lead
so maybe he's just trying to keep that
one point lead because if he wins one
more game he gets to the magic two-point
lead and that will be enough to win the
match we see one of my favorite openings
here the collie this is a really easy
opening to play with the white pieces
because you have a simple attacking plan
Bishop takes H7 is devastating here if
white can play that move he might just
be check mating so for example he's
given us a bad move but uh maybe not for
the reasons
um that was seen there yeah I think
there's 94 ideas he could have played it
earlier uh when there was a pin on the
no nd2 something like that but this
position looks perfectly fine for black
and in fact I prefer Black's position
the semi-open C file is nice for black
to use and now especially that the light
Square Bishops are coming off the board
whoa yeah I I agree and uh that night in
the middle of the board the Black Knight
which White NOW removes was just so
strong but Black's other night has a
beautiful square look at that Knight as
well
um and the bishop blacks pieces finding
tremendous squares here
and is this just an eternal pin like the
pin's not going anywhere you can't move
your king you can't block on the
diagonal and wasn't there Queen takes D3
a moment ago I assuming critics before
that Knight was pinned what happened
there what happened there blue black
just sacrificed the piece he didn't need
to do that Robert there was no need to
sacrifice a piece a time travel does bad
things to us all and look at the clock
all of a sudden Jose is down under 10
seconds he should resign right speaking
of match strategy he needs as much time
remaining as possible and he is down a
full bishop and a full 12 seconds
I agree this is a great time to resign
just make sure you have to keep an eye
on the clock there's no danger for white
here and he does he he makes the right
chords two points up for Andrew now Jose
under a bit of pressure to get a win on
the board
and Andrew goes to the French defense so
an interesting opening Choice by him uh
weight is going to throw those pawns
forward on the king side but black is
saying your King's on the queen side
maybe I can muster up some pressure
against it
I mean his Knight takes F7 here would be
very interesting bringing the black king
out Knight takes Pawn uh in the position
I don't know if it works and that's
probably uh What uh Jose is now thinking
about because he's tanking a lot of time
he decides it doesn't work so that that
could cost him
and now Andrew is the one thinking and
he's trying to figure out a plan because
he brings his Queen back to C7 white
isn't pushing pawns at the board G5 H4
H5 but he goes for this an h7's hanking
so Andrew gives up H7 for F4 I think
that gets him activity but maybe that
King on f8 won't find true shelter
agreed if the Queens come off in this
kind of position black should be better
because Black's Pawn structure is better
uh having more Central pawns but okay
actually now Andrew's taking over the
initiative as well uh he grabs a pawn
this could be a very big game if black
can convert it with two and a half
minutes left but I feel should I feel
white king is safer sorry Simon I feel
like white king is safer right here Rook
H1 and any okay go Rook Edge one I
forgot about the bishop of B7
it's an easy move to miss that one I was
thinking the same use the H file get
your Rook over there I I was thinking
here maybe this could be a crazy thing
to do but maybe Jose no I was thinking
maybe he should resign and just get on
the next game but it's a bit too early
could this be
oh no he's fighting back now
check oh that was a huge blunder and
he's gonna move he goes kicks he wants
to avoid the checks but now checkmate
one
he thought it was check there and he
fell full of the Checkmate and you can
see the disappointment on the video that
was a major win Robert could that be the
match
uh three points with only 120 remaining
unless Andrew loses in it's I think
Jose's a pretty moved the entire game
and that's what he's doing if he can win
this entire game off of pre-moves he has
a shot but you know it's hard to beat
Andrew Tang even when you're moving
slowly in a classical game so beating
him solely off of pre-moves not likely
to happen
I love that idea though uh winning a
winning a game of chess against someone
as strong as Andrew Tang by pre-moving
the whole game I mean that would be
quite legendary and you're right it's
probably the only tactic you can do and
well actually you know black has some
chances here because there's 54 seconds
left so the point being two points is
enough to win and Jose needs to win two
games if he just wins this one game it's
not enough 43 seconds left it's gonna be
quite close if he can get through
I'm keeping an eye on the mass clock and
on the game clock here and C2 there's
Queenie one so he might win this game
but I can sense by Andrew he's probably
looking at the match clock as well and
now it is official I think I'm looking
at the time right there 15 seconds
remaining in the mass clock Andrew has
18 seconds on his clock so he could
always just lose on time and he's
getting checkmated that doesn't really
help but he knows he has made his way
through to face off against Magnus
while only seconds in it and uh wait you
can see what just happened how did he
sit I don't know
I thought that was Checkmate as well
no no I don't care what happened I think
Jose is just pre-moving like non-stop so
he didn't he didn't care about the
Checkmate but this is this is funny
I thought it was Checkmate as well the
next thing the next thing you're losing
we can't even spot check mate anymore
that's how quick and crazy this is well
Andrew wins this game
no way no it's a draw oh my goodness
that would have been you know just add
insult to injury uh but Andrew Tang
moves on to face off against Magnus
Carlson and the game that you can't see
right now on your screen uh they're just
messing around but Andrew Tang he moves
on to loses quarterfinals he takes on
Magnus Carlsen that was a close match
Simon
that was a very close match I mean the
score line maybe at the end I'm amazed
we haven't actually gone through to uh
you know prolonging the matches with tie
breaks because they've been so so close
uh each match and the other thing I
think is I mean Andrew's so relaxed
isn't he he's probably the most relaxed
uh uh player around because this is
bullet chess
um but he doesn't show much emotion very
quietly spoken and I remember in one of
these events he actually had a heart
rate monitor and his heart rate didn't
even go up that much uh my heart rate
would be around 180 I think if I was
playing in this I'd probably just die of
a heart attack but it doesn't happen
with Andrew he's able to control his
emotions so well yeah it's really
unbelievable and he plays engine like
moves and sometimes I guess you have to
be a bit robotic in your demeanor and do
not get phased by what's happening in
the game so with that win Andrew Tang
moves on as we talked about he gets the
face off against Magnus Carlson I'm not
sure still if that's reward if that's a
punishment we know he'll be rewarded
with a minimum six thousand dollar prize
as Jose Martinez leaves with a four
thousand dollar prize but coming up next
we will have Daniel naruditski against
olexona Bortnick and we will also then
get Magnus Carlson against Andrew Tang
but before we get to the next match we
will have a break in an interview and
before we even get there I just you know
I want to make a mention of something we
started the show by wishing everybody a
happy International chess day and we
still want to wish you a happy
International chess day it's still today
unless you're I guess in some parts of
Asia or Australia but if you've been
wanting to try out chess.com premium
features before committing to a
membership now is that time in honor of
international Chess Day cash in on 30
days premium for free enjoy a full month
of unlimited puzzles lessons game review
and more this offer ends on July 27th so
don't miss your chance use the command
claim in chat to unlock 30 days of
Premium right now also right now ask
some questions in chat that you have for
Andrew Tang because on the flip side of
this break we'll bring in the penguin
Jam for an interview and his thoughts
about playing Magnuson next round stay
tuned we'll be right back
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the bow tennis
sisters come on look at this
thechess.com Community streamer program
is growing every day
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
chess.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's always awesome to be joined by the
penguin GM none other than Andrew Tang
Andrew congrats that was a very close
match how do you feel that it went
yeah I think I started it slowly
actually today I felt a little bit
nervous for once
um maybe just because I already lost
ones and Jocelyn's not somebody I had
the best record against actually so
I was definitely feeling like
uh I had a slow start but after that I
think I played pretty well to close out
the match
Andrew you never come across as being
nervous you you seem to be the most
relaxed player I think I've I've ever
met did you have like anything what
helps you relax I mean I need to know
get some of this Magic ingredients
um I don't know I just drink some water
try to clear my mind and
usually that works pretty well but
no special techniques really
well you know you said you got off to a
slow start in this one how do you feel
you were able to change the trajectory
of the match do you feel like it was
just getting warmed up or what did you
do differently
yeah
um I was partly getting warmed up I
think also
sometimes yeah at the start of the match
I'm not like able to be fully focused
sometimes I feel like that was kind of
the case I was playing a little bit
slowly at the beginning and
once I got into the match I feel like I
just tend to play better in general
I take a long time sometimes
and entry like historically
um who is like your hardest opponent
maybe in this competition or in general
in but it's just
I think car is a bad matchup for me like
against Magnus I think maybe my chances
are a little bit better because
um I tend to flag him sometimes from
Lost positions and you can see Carl he
is a little bit faster but also he's so
tricky like I get winning positions
against him all the time and then
he like tricks you three times and you
lose and then you're tilted and then
next game he tricks you two times and
yeah just for some reason like you can't
hold on to these winning positions
against him
and then it's also hard to flag him so I
don't know
yeah I think nobody has the exact
Solution on taking Town Hikaru but you
did just beat Jose Martinez you are
going to face Magnus in a little bit and
we have a feature chat question from EPS
91 saying do you prepare differently
when you have two matches on the same
day
um
I mean I prepared a little bit for
Jocelyn and I didn't think about Magnus
at all
I just focused on the first match and I
figured
maybe I can prepare a little bit for
Magnus before the match right now but
yeah I I don't know I try not to Tire
myself out too much especially when it's
bullet like
as long as I play well I think that's
more important than doing a lot of
preparation
we better not keep you too long then
Andrew because you you know it's
probably takes a while to prepare
something against Magnus I mean I don't
know how you can predict any openings he
will play uh but we do we do have a
question from the chat and this was uh
the question was how would you rate your
play out of 10 at the moment I guess
based on that last match
I don't know I think
probably like a five I feel like
this was pretty much
approximately what I expected from the
match so
I'm not too happy or too unhappy about
how I played hopefully I can play better
against Magnus but definitely need to
play a little bit better
to have a good chance against Magnus
well you know the fans are never
displeased to see you play we're always
appreciative of your time and we're
gonna let you go because you are facing
Magnus later today and good luck in that
match and congrats once again on beating
Joss from there
thank you
and that is Andrew Tang who moves on to
the losers quarterfinals he secures
himself minimum six thousand dollars in
prize money and he faces Magnus Carlson
later today but first we do get the
Sensei the Prophet Daniel nerdinski
taking on his good friend somebody he
works with courses on and works on
courses with like you can't even speak
we've seen so much Bull in my head is uh
in a whirlwind but Simon Donya versus
Bortnick we heard bortnick's thoughts do
you think Dania will be prepared and
will he be rusty at all because as
Andrew just told us sometimes it takes a
bit of time to warm up
it does yeah and especially at bullet
chess I mean even if you're like a
couple of percentage of your mouse speed
or your Tactical ability it it costs
that little bit more that much more
because you you know it's quick and fast
um I expect Danya he's very experienced
to playing bullet he'd be in a good
frame mood and uh uh I this match again
like today's all of the matches today
will be very very close it was
interesting to hear uh earlier uh bought
Nick mentioned you know playing your
friends is difficult
um but he also said there's no there's
no friends when you start the game right
it is just a battle and everyone at this
level has played their friends in the
past and uh uh you've just gotta you
know you just gotta fight them it's as
simple as that so uh forget who you're
playing play the board instead and I
don't know about you Robert do you have
you ever struggled playing people you
know who are very friendly with you
you know I just don't make new friends
that way I don't have to say it's a
tough time against someone I like no in
all seriousness it is difficult to play
somebody that you're friends with and
especially somebody that you worked with
I think that changes the nature of the
matchup completely because uh if they've
worked on openings with you if you've
given kind of your secret files and
things that you're working on that could
be very difficult and Donya you know we
know that he created this course with
Bortnick but we also know that Donya has
been rated over
35.50 in bullet chess on chess.com he's
been in third place in the last three
years in the BCC uh his YouTube
viewership goes up every single day and
he was the 2022 chess.com commentator of
the year so friends are not
Donya is a Powerhouse in bullet chess
and I think he will also be able to put
the Friendship aside for 30 minutes
100 and uh I I must say to anyone in the
chat if you if you haven't checked out
Daniel's YouTube channel or or subscribe
to his twitch Channel then shame on you
you've got to do the walk of shame
because it's very educational and a lot
of fun both of his channels so you can
check those channels out and uh bought
Nick as well has his own twitch channel
so one of the one of the great things
about modern chess is you can follow
your favorite players live
um predictions I think we we need to put
our neck on the line it's only fair and
uh obviously for that reason I'll let
you go first Robert okay since someone
has to uh go first I'll do that I think
that Dania is a heavy favorite uh
Bortnick is really really good and what
we saw earlier today there were some
great moments from Bortnick but I just
think that match was much closer than
the match that Dania had against
paravian and also no one is happy when
they lose a match but I think Donna can
be pretty happy with how he lost that
match Jay car yesterday there were some
fantastic tactics in all those fireworks
he was able to come out on top in a
bunch of games so I do think that Dania
is the favorite and will get the job
done and Simon I know sometimes co-com
theaters they like one one person picks
one player the other picks the second
don't tell me you're gonna pick Bortnick
just to disagree with me
well I'm gonna pick Bortnick uh just to
disagree with you Robert and
um you know I I well I mean I I say that
a little bit of Jessica's uh Daniel is
just uh he's got more experience uh he's
a little bit more trickier but they're
both so fantastic and I think in a short
time limit like this only half an hour
you know the difference is less I think
uh the underdog can win so let's make it
interesting I'll go for bought Nick just
to spice it up a little bit don't don't
tell Daniel that though if he wins okay
you promise I won't tell him like you
told Daniel that I put my bet on Tang so
there's a lot of snakes in this match
sorry I'll forgive you eventually some
you know not having the Goldfish
short-term memory loss so here we see
the winner is guaranteed eight thousand
dollars the loser is awarded 6K so a 2
000 difference once again uh bordick
doing this for the second time today and
the winner advantages to the losers
semis well they'll await of some very
tough competition there's no one easy
left but the winner of Carlson and Tang
so Bortnick you predicted that he can
make this upset happen he was a finalist
in 2019 he lost only to a car Nakamura
after beating Alexander grushook and
Maxine rusher lagrav I agree completely
that in shorter amounts of games and 30
minutes of bullet chess that yeah the
underdog does have a chance but Dania
naroditsky he has been in great shape
throughout the entire BCC including
yesterday's loss in the match against
Hikaru he beat tang in a very one-sided
Affair I just feel like Dania wants it
and he is proving it over the board
yes he does seem really motivated and um
he's going to be a very tight he's
always a very tough opponent this is
going to be a big big match let's remind
everyone again they're playing for that
difference of two thousand dollars uh
it's big money at stake and uh it's also
one of the last losers games the loser
of this is knocked out of the
competition you do not get another
chance so
um nerves they could be playing a part
of this match yeah and even Andrew said
that he was nervous against Jose because
it was his last life so if Andrew Tang
gets nervous you know that the other
players are likely nervous as well and I
cannot wait for this match to begin
because uh Bortnick he and Dania are
good friends they play against Joe all
the time on stream I know that in person
they hang out quite often and play
Marathon Blitz sessions so we'll see
will friendship Prevail uh will they
still be friends at the end of this I
think the answer is yes but they will
not be friends during
and we have some moves already so again
the opening stage of this match I think
is going to be very interesting uh
because they both play quite similar
openings they both have worked on the
same opening so they might have some
surprises in store and Who's Gonna Get
The Edge in the opening we'll find out
and well who who's better here Robert do
we think
I typically like not having double Pawns
in a bullet chest or Blitz chest because
I feel like sometimes they're vulnerable
but here I definitely love having a
knight and that night is stationed on D4
it's an outpost but Simon I'm looking at
the King march for white is this King
just trying to go this way go to B2 at
some point and go after the A5 Pawn I
guess it's a little too late you just
dropped H2
yeah but it's the Knight getting out of
jail I mean you have to go H5 and bring
the knights out and maybe your King
march works there I mean uh it's uh very
interesting we could see if you take the
Knight and now March your king towards
even though you're pulling down in this
ending
um okay he's trying to lock things up
instead so white strategy is not gonna
allow the black king in and I'm just
gonna hold the draw in this position
black though has G5 and to my eyes this
is just a winning plan and black does
take the first game uh Daniel one little
up there yes and so Daniel takes that
first game there he should be quite
thrilled uh sorry Bortnick takes that
and so yeah it's good news for Sasha
Bortnick fans and good news for you
Simon who predicted that Bortnick will
take this match
aha okay yeah and uh I I like his
opening he's played here this is another
one of uh I've done a chessboard course
on this can you believe it or not this
bishop E2 move and it's a really um uh
Sly variation where white just tries to
build up the center against the Sicilian
and White's got an ideal situation uh
here he's got the good Center and he's
got chances to attack black so
um uh I I got my colors mixed up there I
apologize in the last game it does get a
bit quick even for me and um it must be
white who's better here surely
or whites up a pawn but D4 is weak uh we
just acknowledge that the evil bar
hasn't moved an inch we are working on
that so please bear with us but the D4
Pawn that's on a dark Square only black
has a dark Square Bishop so there are
trade-offs here extra material for white
but the pawns that are weak are
unfortunately for white as well
and now that the Queens have come off
I'm pretty sure that does help black a
lot because one of the problems with
that pawn structure when you have the
more space is that it's easier to attack
from a position of space but the attack
becomes less dangerous when the Queens
are exchanged saying that very complex
situation on the board here time could
be the most important thing and Daniel
has an extra 13 seconds here
important and he said it in his
interview earlier today against paravian
he said I was just moving too slowly
somehow I was down 15 seconds and he's
down 10 plus seconds right here it
doesn't matter how many pieces he's up
as long as he doesn't deliver Checkmate
Donya wins yeah Johnny gives away his
Rook moves the bishop back 12.2 second
time difference that's way too much in a
match like this
that is a big big time difference so
that that was certainly play a major
part as things go on and um we're into
the other game King's Indian defensive
very symmetrical scenario
um so not much to say at this moment but
who's up on the clock well at least in
this one uh Bortnick is moving quicker
he probably realizes uh that time is uh
something he's got to improve
yes and we see this position where the
bishop uh see the bishop pair and I
don't even have time to get the sentence
out it was a bishop pair for white but a
bishop pair no more now it's just
opposite colored Bishops but B2 that
pawn on the dark Square it can't go
anywhere so right now Bishop takes B2 is
meant by Rook takes F7 check some fancy
tactics uh from White
yes and it seems like white has well I
guess it's fairly even at the moment in
time lots of pawns are getting hoovered
off white does have the extra Pawn but
it's not a poem you can do much with
saying that I'd rather have the extra
Pawn of course uh a draw looking like
the most likely result but the time
situation again just look at that this
is where Daniel could have the major
advantage he he's up 15 seconds and uh
the botnik is is gonna have to improve
this scenario with the clock
and look it down it brings his Bishop to
A4 to protect the B3 pawn it frees up
his Rook he makes a pawn move remember
how draws work in chess 50 moves without
a capture or a pawn push and now it
doesn't matter because Black's pieces
are falling off but Dania you know he's
doing this perfectly he makes a bunch of
moves burn some of the clock then pushes
his pawns and now his pawns won't stop
pushing until they become a queen
yeah and that gives him the lead in the
match very nicely played there from
Dania and they're into the next one this
bishop B2 move it's actually quite a
quite a good little opening system this
um he was favored by some English
players who started playing it about 15
years ago and some other players at
Belarusian Grandmaster as well and it's
like a reverse Dutch opening
um but has white fallen into a bit of an
uncomfortable pin there quite possibly
you don't really want to double your
pawns like this uh the reason white
plays is opening is because of those two
pawns you can see
um there but things going a little bit
wrong for white here
yeah what just happened I feel like so
many pieces were captured in a row and
suddenly it is black who's not even up a
pawn it looks like it because white has
these double pawns and also these
isolated pawns on the queen side but
it's weight lose up a pawn not caring
about the back rank the king is not
going to get checkmated over there so
some Brave play from portnick
yes and it seems like this is going to
be his opening choice for the match
which I'm happy about uh saying that
black I mean blacks Rooks look at them
they're now coming straight into the
position and black has picked up a piece
there a big blunder
um from uh boat neck in there quite a
quite a good position there
yeah Bortnick needed that one to tie the
match up now Dania has a three to one
lead and he should be very happy to pick
up a piece thanks to a night Fork Dino's
putting pressure on the clock and that's
been really bad news for Bortnick
this is a miserable opening as well for
black I mean if you're going to play
this system which is called the English
defense
you you can't play you can't play as
passively as this you have to play a bit
more active the black king well if it
can get castle black will be okay and it
looks like that might be possible right
um it has it's Castle black is okay now
yes and he just went C5 allowing white
to keep a pass part in the position and
Daniel coming up with tricks right if
you took the pawn 97 check something
your Rook on D6 was loose so board Nick
can be some Brave decision thus far and
they really are paying off
yeah and uh he's getting very active
with pieces and now threatening a bishop
check that Bishop check will be a major
problem for white here uh so white has
to give his King an escape square and
look at Black's pieces they're flooding
into the position and uh it should be
really good for black but again the time
do not get behind on the time you're up
on time bought Nick just remember stay
up on the clock
oh that's gonna do it though the G2 Pawn
falling is a big problem but oh wow what
tactical awareness Bishop 82
wow unreal how many people would have
actually played that move Robert when
there were so many other movies and that
was a great win uh for Bortnick from a
very bad position uh could that be uh
the change in the scenario now
do you see that mating pattern for
Bortnick he saw that right instantly he
saw it in advance maybe he's the prophet
after all and Bortnick now cut the
deficit in half it's only one point
spread and he gets the white pieces in
this game he plants a knight on e4 we've
seen this at the highest level black
isn't really worse but players they like
to play against this dark Square bishop
and say doesn't have the best of
diagonals
yeah like in the night here because it
has that square in the middle of the
board
um but I guess well black does swap that
Knight off for that reason
not liking the double Pawn so much
nobody really does especially when
they're isolated in the center like this
and keeping the Queens on the board is
of course smart because Dania is up a
lot of time and he has the attacking
chances as the black uh the dark Square
pawns and the black dark Square bishop
and that's the same color and white on
the other hand can't get that Bishop
active
yeah
and he's picking up pawns now as well
and look at that the black queen swings
in and this is gonna be really bad for
white white now two pawns down even if
the Queens are exchanged it could be a
winning position for black for those
connected pawns but Daniel deciding I'm
going to keep the Queens on because your
king is weaker than mine very that's a
very instructive thing that he's doing
there only swapping Queens when he has
to
now that's why I have any drawing
chances here I think now he's got a
blockade there are drawing chances well
the reason there aren't is just uh the
clock is I'm looking at the time and
done is ahead and if I see Daniel up oh
that was a bad decision though now
actually it's very easy for white to
pre-move
yeah
I guess white can pre-move with the
bishop the whole game right so but look
at his time
oh this is quite this is quite sickening
it's like who can move the mouse the
quicker here
and Dania is the mouse champion
and you know what's interesting is
Bortnick was making long Bishop moves
they take a little bit more time but
he's pretty oh my gosh he got the 50
move rule up with 0.3 seconds left that
is how quickly they play that was
unbelievable
wow that is bullet chess for you and
that is why I hate it
that is why I'm so bad at the game
because you have to move so quickly 50
moves with point three of a second left
holding the draw and this match is maybe
closer than people had assumed it would
be there's only one point in it and I
have to say Black's position here looks
quite nice to me I prefer to be black
open file winning a pawn could be a
chance to equal the score
yes Bortnick is playing really well ever
since dropping two games to dania he was
down by two now he feels like he is the
one in charge he's up a pawn he has
control of the second rank with that
Rook sliding now to A2 attacking another
Pawn so just gaining extra material move
by move
and we're also uh very nicely going
through the colors of the rainbow on the
chessboard which I like
and I'm never sure which color I like
best I've tried out lots of different
combinations to see if I play better
with a certain color
um Robert come on what color do you like
of the chessboard I know it's a random
question but I've got to ask what color
do I like on the chessboard
um
I have never so I'm appreciative that
you asked me about my feelings you know
a lot of my co-commentators they don't
care but you do care I I don't think I
have a preference though do you what
about you
I like the green I like a bit of green
so this one's a nice one I approve
definitely improved for the green board
and we should probably go back to the
chess and um it looks all of a sudden
that Daniel has tricked or Nick again
look at those two pawns and his time is
just too big here again this is maybe
what's going to be the telling point and
you predicted this uh as well uh Robert
that the time could be the major factor
and uh
Big Win there yeah no that did look at
that time differential at the end 15
seconds and Bortnick he knows he said it
himself about his match against paravian
but he also might be tilting right now
because he just went Knight takes D5
he's hacking The Black Queen on F6 and
Donya slide his Queen over the bishop on
E3 is in trouble and you take that first
you take the Knight before extra piece
for Just Two Pawns
yes so another problematic position and
that could also be an issue
um okay he's threatening a crafty check
mate there
and
you can't get the open file here as
white that's that's a problem
no no attack you know you want to push
some Pawns in front of the black king
but you only have a knight over there
and that's it
yeah
I think I was looking at the wrong board
there so just to confuse you all you
know maybe I am color blind who knows
what's happening is you have you have
one for everyone else no we that's the
thing that you were selling your arrows
before you were drawing arrows on your
board but my board is the one that's
showing up on the broadcast so now
people get inside behind the scenes why
sometimes we're both confused but I
think Dania is not confused that was
Checkmate and now that means his lead
has ballooned up to three points
three points is a is a big score to come
back from I mean there's still time uh
but you've got to get rolling now this
is the moment if you go to Four Points
it's not good
blank's position here I think I'd prefer
it you want to have the attacking
chances
maybe swing The Rook around get that
Knight into the center
yeah no this this outpost on D4 is very
valuable and bornik seems to like this
structure he doesn't care about the
double pawns but E5 thrown there to
shatter their Pawn Sharks are for black
but it cost a pawn and I don't think you
have sufficient play for it
no it doesn't look like it um
um this has to be black hat I think has
to get this one like has to get this
game
he's got the extra Pawn okay it's not a
great extra Pawn but it's still a pawn
your Rook is much more active
great defensive yellow from White the
Knight finds a beautiful Square the
White Knight defending everything and
now White's Rook goes active at the same
time uh this ending well okay good
winning chances you've got to move your
king in at the right time and here comes
the black king should probably be
winning for black
time though time is also good you've got
to win this game yeah you need black
pieces he better not get a repetition I
push the pawn that starts the counter
all over again and he can just bring his
King up I think he's a little bit
nervous about that but he can try to win
on the board and also try to win on the
clock because Dania for a change is the
one down on time
yeah get your Rook off the C1 square
that is the way it did but this is maybe
not the way to play because now your
King has no Escape Square I think black
may have thrown away the win he's got a
win on time now this is the only way
because the king just can't get in look
at the black king he needs to throw an
effort to do yeah he did it and he's
still up on time so this is gonna be
close down it is very fast but bornick
as well and he has it if he gets his
Rook out the way
oh
he is getting it born he gets it done
0.9 seconds remaining
very important win there that that had
to be done to keep the match within
grasp and uh now I think it's just a
two-point lead and
the black king a little bit weak here if
you can start an attack against it after
you lose the bishop in front Shield King
it becomes the target
yeah so we see that Bortnick with the
white pieces he's not really getting
much of anything right now the King on
G7 can be exposed in some of these
positions of the dark squares but white
has no Firepower in front of it and I
think this is just gonna cost quite a
pawn
yeah and black is nicely situated with
his pieces they're all controlling in
the middle section of the board
um there goes maybe another Pawn as well
even though the evaluation bar has seen
something and wait in the blink of an
eye picks up a couple of Pawns
too quick for me to see how but he's
done it I could roughly even position
now are you bury all my eyes what is
happening all the pieces are
disappearing and now it looks like it's
in even by material endgame but Black's
pawns are split so I would prefer
White's chances
yeah time Advantage
um for
Daniel and there goes the porn so um
what's going on here so black with the
lead on time by a lot but white has
removed Black's last Pawn I actually
feel like there's some good chances here
for uh black because of the clock
yeah agreed I think this is fairly even
actually I mean even though your two
pawns up and you're winning on the
chessboard the time situation is you're
10 seconds down and uh that is ticking
away and there goes one Pawn as well so
very easy to get flagged here and that
is the big difference with bullet chess
it's the clock and look at the speed
that Daniel's Moving he's just
harnessing that clock and you know
what's been so amazing about this is the
oh except for that move nine to five the
evaluation never changed because Donya
was the pointing pins he wins the game
on position but he really won because of
the clock an extra four and a half
seconds for him and he avoided all the
pins he just knows what his opponent's
about to do and he then he knows how to
place his King in response it's
exceptional
you mentioned this yesterday oh the day
before yesterday wrote when I was
commentating that the difference between
like uh your standard amazing player
um and your um more amazing player like
you know the top four players in bullet
is there um how they can predict what
their opponent is going to do and
actually prepare and pre-move for their
pre-move and that might sound completely
ridiculous but Daniel just showed it
there he was pre-moving for his
opponent's pre-move uh and I don't ask
me how you get this skill but it's like
some kind of uh Jedi mind trick even
right uh that the top guys have and
Dania has that
um and it's helping him get the extra
points here
it's truly ridiculous
I don't have that myself I don't know
how these players do it but the ability
to accurately predict what your opponent
is doing when they're moving in 0.1 to
0.6 seconds it's incredible and in this
game white is now up a pawn and so Dania
he's going to try to press the Rook
takes E3 that was missed by Don very
clearly and I think that should save the
game for Bortnick
yeah black Black is Black is okay yeah
I'm just about
yeah the clock and that past April well
it's an extra passport
no big one no good because Daniel's just
gonna move his King around a bunch if he
needs to give up the a pawn to not have
a repetition he'll do just that so his
King will go back here it goes and
they'll play Queen F2 exactly
oh oh
okay and he won he's one old time he won
by Checkmate once oh a game oh my words
look at Daniel hitting his head there
that shouldn't he should not have lost
that game and then he's tilting big
moment
look at his face he's giving his Queen
again two I'm gonna I don't do this in
ever but here in this game
after Bishop B5 check he Mouse slipped
with Queen to D7 double question mark
I'll go back to the live position but he
put his Queen in front of the bishop to
lose it he meant to play Bishop D7 so he
lost his Queen in the last game didn't
see the queen on A3 covering the f8
square he lost his queen that game
because he unfortunately clicked his
Queen instead of his Bishop now it is
suddenly a one point match
in the blink of an eye in the blink of
an eye it went from a very commanding
lead for danger who looked like he was
going to go four points up to only being
one point up and what's that gonna do
for your for your spirit as well you're
gonna you know no matter who you are
you're gonna be feeling pretty bad so
this is this is a game he's got to stop
the rot now or can what make level to
score
he's got a big time advantage this
position is wild right now whoa Bishop
H7
wait he's going for mate okay I guess he
has a draw by repetition so that allows
white to take the half point so what
Daniel might do is he might make the
two-time repetition and then spend a
bunch of time before he makes the third
that way he wastes some of the match
clock
but the match is quite close there's
only one point in it I mean you know
does he feel like he that's a good
strategy it's really hard to know the
right gameplay and I think he feels like
I'm gonna I need a bigger lead before I
start wasting time and um we can see
here that they're straight into the next
game
isolated Pawn position the kind of
position where actually white generally
has the easier position to play because
you can just attack H7 that pawn by
Black's King
always nice to attack in bullet chess
here
yeah no it is nice to attack for sure
and I was just thinking about this that
uh perhaps Dania is happy about that
draw because what you learn is you don't
want to Castle Queen side not talking
that's why I went on the chessboard I'll
talk about losing three games in a row
so Daniel made that quick draw he did
not lose another game and he has a great
position with black that outpost on D5
the bishop on D2 is pretty useless
unless down your blunders Bishop takes
H6 but actually he had the F5 the engine
went all the way down it's clear that
there was a tactic it was the move F5
and he has it once again like right now
F5 yeah great tattoo there I I love your
Castle Queen side I've never thought
about it uh three losses in a row like
that and I I maybe I've never lost three
games in a row Robert do you believe
that
um I maybe since you became a GM I could
believe that but I think when everyone
is Young the castle queenside
I think our Castle Queen so far too
often and um that was another win for
Daniel who again takes the lead to two
points seven and a half minutes to go
yeah eight to six lead for Dania and
that was a really a needed win I think
for his morale and in this game he's up
a pawn and I'm not seeing how black gets
that back on E5
disgusting position for black uh this
one I'm afraid to say uh for botnik fans
because um it's not just that okay he
does get the pawn back but it seems like
White's pawns on the king side are gonna
Rush up the board soon the white Rook
penetrates into the position
maybe F4 even here is a move and he
plays it not black is just so passive
black doesn't have many active moves
here and look at those pawns now coming
out the board yeah and Bortnick tries to
attack some pawns with his Queen and
donuts all right you attack my Pawn I
simply push it up the board and well G4
he wants to take on H3 because there's
Rook H1 ideas and he's just pushing all
of his pieces forward and blacks Knight
and f8 normally we talk about Bishops
not really being a bishop is that Knight
really a knight when it can't get out
can't move anywhere I mean you can try
to come round to where the king is but
it's completely stuck and I can see the
white Bishop uh re-routing itself but a
lovely way to break through there and
the white pawns on the queen side look
too strong
we move if that Brook was captured then
the C Pawn takes and promotes idanya is
on fire right now
amazing tactic there and um a brilliant
win from Daniel there just spotting that
check uh so quickly was incredible
and this okay how much time do we have
we have six minutes we have um I think
it's a three-point lead so we're getting
into a situation again where botnik
needs I feel to win this game with the
white pieces and and a position he can
attack in maybe Black's okay here but
the point is the black king has nowhere
safe it can really go to
right it's a part sacrifice but there's
definite compensation if you Castle King
so you have to watch out for F5 Pawn
Pusher so that's why Daniel keeps his
King in the center until the right
moment and he may never Castle depending
on what happens the next few moves
he's doing a good job of Defending
though even though black hasn't got his
rook in the corner out the rook and
queen that are developed are doing a
great job here and somehow white needs
to activate his pieces but looking like
black is playing just really well at the
moment accurate moves
some attack here against White's King as
well The Rook comes to B3 and the queen
into GD he's just inching his way
forward here that B2 Pawn is weak the
black king is safe and for Bortnick if
he lose this game as a four point
deficit
and he just lost by Checkmate so Dania
another
got a borderline perfect game from him
yeah that might be the the game that has
done the job
um I there could be a chance if you can
win a couple of games quickly but it's
four games and there's four and a half
minutes I feel that means Dania has done
the job Robert
um so you win you win the prediction
round again I'm not very good with these
predictions am I I'm gonna have to
improve I think you let me go first
which forced your hand because you just
want to disagree with me uh Daniel is
the favorite in matchups against bornek
but as you've seen throughout this match
Bortnick is really strong and another
day I mean another match it could have
gone his way here look at this Dania has
locked up the position completely and
he's just gonna make random moves for a
while and hope that Bortnick doesn't try
to go Queen takes G5 and catch him to
pre-move
this is very good match strategy you get
completely locked position you run the
clock down even if you somehow lose this
position you you've wasted a couple of
minutes uh just to guarantee uh that
that the match is yours I expect at some
point we might see Dania celebrate I
think one thing uh you kind of avoid
doing when you're playing a friend is
overly celebrating I mean I remember a
horrible situation where
um I was playing a very important game I
I lost the game
and then the the girlfriend of the
opponent I lost to came running in and
started Snogging him in front of me and
I was like come on just please you know
I've just lost the horrible game I don't
want to see that just don't do it please
so I think you know the match is
effectively over but we might not see uh
a Daniel celebration here who knows
this game do it move around by the way
everybody you have no idea you would
think you'd oh I'm with 35. we're on
move 110 and they still dinosaurs 10
seconds left so I'm just looking at the
timer I see that white is winning now
black is catching up I don't even care
about the board anymore we are about to
hit move 100
35 135 was our final move they played
135 moves in a one minute game
yeah that's that's just too many moves
isn't it too many moves of bullet and uh
again good strategy right players when
you're when you're leading the match and
uh uh you can see that both players are
relaxing a bit there it's so tense
playing this kind of time limit the the
stress just must be immense and um well
they've got to play on until the buzzer
is down and this should probably be our
penultimate game uh black currently down
a pawn but D3 doesn't look like it's
long for this board and now it is
scooped up by Dania So Daniel nerdinski
he came to play he means serious
business he wants to improve
on last year's performance and the two
years before that
when he ended in third place and I I do
believe that he feels he has a chance
against anybody in this competition of
course Ali Reza and Hikaru they're in
the winners a final that will happen
later today but Donya showed yesterday
against Hikaru that on his best day he
can compete with even the best players
on the planet and he is taking board
Nick to school right now
yes yeah I mean he's got another chance
I mean that's the exciting thing about
this double elimination I really I
really like this format
um by the way some crazy tactics on the
board here the White Knight threatened
the queen and Checkmate but it's nice
that you can lose one match and you get
that next shot and just while uh you
know we watch the end of this match
let's remind everyone who is playing
next because uh well we we have maybe
the greatest player of all time Magnus
Carlson
possibly playing against the quickest
player of all time Andrew Tang so uh
it's it's gonna be a great match that
one as well looking at this white okay a
rook up but obviously there's no reason
for black to resign
um with the time situation 40 seconds to
go probably one more game after this as
you as you said Robert
and Dante gets that one and maybe I'll
take one more for the road because he
has just been the faster player today
and as Simon was just mentioning up next
will be Magnus Carlson against Andrew
tang and if that weren't enough for you
we will finish the day with 45 minutes
the time Patrol slightly longer another
time Patrol excuse me the uh time for
the match slightly longer in the winners
bracket we will have a car Nakamura and
Ali Reza farouza playing 45 minutes of
one minute chess so it's been really a
great start to the day and it's only
maybe getting better as Magnus appears
in a car later today but Dania is the
person we should talk about he's played
a really strong match and in this final
game Simon the black king doesn't look
very safe to my eyes I don't see an easy
way out for Bortnick
no all the whites pieces are just
converging around the black king even
though black is material that's pretty
irrelevant when uh when you're attacking
I don't know if there's a killer blow
here but increasing the pressure like
this makes a lot of sense you can take
that pawn Checkmate now threatened on
the board
um computer doesn't like it but I I like
threatening Checkmate and that that
looks good enough to me this will be the
last match and you can see the
disappointment on both Nick's face but
at least he got the extra two thousand
dollars by winning his first match today
right and here he looks pretty
frustrated with what just happened but
Daniel naroditsky as you said no huge
celebration from him I'm sure he feels
for Bortnick he advances to the loser
semi-final that was a one-sided Affair
by the end of the match but earlier on
Bortnick gave Donya everything he could
handle
Daniel's just too strong in that match
and a little bit too quick so
um it seemed at one point that sport
Nick was getting back into it but then
again Dania got his dominance by winning
the next couple of games so uh exciting
match and there we see the final score
13-6 in the end Daniel goes on a run to
finish things off he blunder his Queen a
couple times that wasn't ideal he saw
him get upset and he was beside I was
like what am I doing how did I just lose
my queen in two consecutive games but it
doesn't matter in the end because all
that matters is you win your match you
move on in the bracket and Donya he now
knows that he awaits the winner of the
match we're about to see between Andrew
tang and Magnus Carlson and we are
definitely going to interview Dania
before that match takes place so I mean
Simon really just Stellar stuff from
Dunya
yeah I just played very very strong and
we will have it into I think quite
shortly uh with Daniel and and just to
remind everyone again there's two great
matches to go we we've got a Magnus
Carlson playing next against Andrew Tang
then finish off the day well maybe the
match that everyone is is uh excited
about is the match between two previous
winners Hikaru Nakamura versus alireza
farouza uh that is going to be
tremendous
oh it certainly will and for now we'll
head to break but please leave your
questions for Donya we will feature a
few of them so please get involved and
we will see you on the flip side of this
break with Grandmaster Daniel nerdiski
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account don't stays connected
it's pretty sweet and it's going to help
you get better learning from the
mistakes in your games yes this is a pro
feature accessible but if you go to
accessible.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
in game we've added a new classification
called Miss for when a move fails to
take advantage of an opportunity but it
is otherwise a sound move we've also
changed the definition of blunder now a
move will only be considered a blunder
if it loses material or allows a
Checkmate coach will now draw arrows and
highlight squares when you hover over or
click on the highlighted words in the
move explanation this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess.com
right now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
he's a Grandmaster who needs no
introduction but he deserves one after
that great display of bullet technique
this is Daniel naroditsky Dania congrats
how you feeling after that win over your
good friend Alexander
well I'm feeling good about the match
that was the definition of topsy-turvy
obviously I absolutely hate to play my
close friends Sasha is just he's a Class
Act he's you know five times the the
bullet player that I am um I was just
winning purely on the clock uh and
that's normally how I beat him so you
know my apologies to Sasha uh he played
great but it does feel good to advance
you know I I really do want to play
Magnus this tournament not that Magnus
Tang is a walkover so I'm glad to be
back in the tournament but once again my
you know my apologies to Sasha and uh he
he had a great tournament as well
yeah well done on the victory there uh
Daniel and um I mean you mentioned uh
you you were getting lots of tricks in
and winning on time I mean that that I
think is part of bullet is what makes it
better in the end but uh do you have any
I mean how how do you move so quickly I
mean do you ever practice your mouse
skills I was wondering or do you just
never
not once I've never done and I know
people don't believe me but I've never
done aim trainer but I have done aim
trainer it's called bullet aim trainer
is hyper bullet like you don't need to
do anything you know other than play
bullet I think it's just the amount of
games that I've played you have to
develop good aim to play in those time
scrambles and that was sort of my
pre-match strategy I watched Sasha's
match against David and I noticed that
Sasha was struggling on the clock
tremendously so I was constantly forcing
myself to play even faster than I'm used
to in the opening particularly get that
15 second lead and then burn that 15
seconds on two or three critical moments
in the middle game but to Circle back
your question no I I've never done
anything special when I have tried aim
trainer on stream I'm pretty mediocre so
I don't know what it is
no you don't have to have the knowledge
of what it is as long as you get it done
which you did and uh I have a question
for you about nerves because we had
Andrew on earlier after his match
Victory and he said you know for once he
was nervous because it's double
elimination but you're on your last life
did you feel a little bit more nervous
today after yesterday's loss to icaro
I felt a little bit more nervous today
after I blundered my queen two times in
a row I was actually fairly calm
um there's always Jitters that accompany
the first two or three games so once I
got that early lead I was actually the
picture of calmness I was like this is I
got this in the bag I'm feeling
confident you know I'm starting to
outplay them on the board then I play
Queen f8 and then the next game my mouse
of Queen D7 and then all of that calm
was chucked over to South Carolina uh so
that's when all hell broke loose I mean
it always does in these bullet matches
so the second half I was a nervous wreck
the first half I was you know a Zen Monk
and if you put those two together I
guess I was a little bit calmer than I
was against icaro because it doesn't
matter what the situation is when you're
playing Hikaru it's just so anxiety
inducing the pressure that he puts on
you is second to none uh so I was a
little bit calmered today I came to
terms with the fact that if I lose again
it's a win-win for us because then Sasha
goes through and I'd be really happy for
him so uh I wasn't you know thinking of
this as okay if I lose I die and the
tournament is over I've done well
already I think I've proven what I
wanted to prove and at this point I'm
just uh playing for extra credit so to
speak
and Dania you mentioned obviously Hikaru
and how he puts pressure opponents I
mean what do you think it is that you
know makes Hikaru that little bit better
or that little bit more dangerous than
other players is his ability to set
tricks or is there something else there
you can pinpoint in his play
well I agree to this assessment
yesterday I think one thing that's not
talked about enough there's two things
the first is openings it seems to me
that people don't realize how how well
Hikaru feels the positions that he gets
and as I talked about in an earlier
interview in bullet it's not about how
many moves of a chessable course can I
remember it's can I get positions where
I know the ideas and I feel the
positions and Hikaru is a beast at
adjusting his opening choices to his
opponent so yesterday he was playing
Vienna which I find to be very
unpleasant against E4 he played some
alicines of black which I don't like
playing it so he feels exactly what to
play uh to make his opponent
uncomfortable and his opening repertoire
is so Universal that you know it's like
you walk into a restaurant you've got a
10 page menu uh and he can choose the
dish off the menu That's most unpleasant
to his opponent but the other thing is
that Hikaru is a technician and people
think of him as a tactical player of
course he's Universal in his style but
the way that he converts advantages is
Second To None like when you get a bad
position against him and you're 5 10
seconds down on the clock the feeling of
hopelessness is one that I don't get
against anybody else because this is
what I made my bullet career out of
right I get lost positions every second
game and then I weasel out of it I had a
couple of those yesterday but it's just
this total feeling of hopelessness when
you're losing and you're like well I
must be up on the clock it must have
taken him a lot of time to get that
position and you look and he has 45
seconds and you have 20 seconds so just
uh all-out assault on the clock on the
board and the openings in the end games
his technique obviously his sight of one
or two move tactics it's the whole
package and it really isn't just one
thing I think
wow that was you know really elaborate
description of what makes the Colorado
cars and thank you for that uh but you
know you mentioned the discomfort that a
car puts you in you also touched upon
the discomfort is playing your friends
so Johnny Baker asked the question is it
hard playing against your friends you
answer that but I guess to spin off of
that how do you deal with that
discomfort when you're playing somebody
that you're close to like you are with
Bortnick
well as Sasha said in the earlier
interview there are no friends on the
board so there's a mutual understanding
and a lot of the credit goes to Sasha uh
that you know when we're facing each
other in a match nothing is personal so
me flagging him rook and Knight versus
rook and Knight in two pons is because I
I want to win the match and uh it has
nothing to do with any personal enemy
into the contrary so it is unpleasant
afterward and before because we know
that you know we want each other to
succeed and I want him to to win the
bull championship and it's it's hard
when I myself uh have to have to stop
his run or vice versa but I think it's
very important to have this
understanding that you got to play the
exact same way that you would against
anybody else and you owe that to a real
friend
um and and I like the fact that he would
never hold any of this against me and
again vice versa so you know you push
all of that away you play the 30 minute
match and then you meet in the evening
have dinner and raise a glass to the
person who advanced
a nice explanation there Daniel and um a
question from the chat here and um it is
who do you think sorry who do you think
you have the better chance against in
the semi-finals
tough question wait what are the choices
Magnus or Tang again
oh Magnus versus tank okay um just
making sure well
um obviously I beat Andrew earlier in
the tournament but I think the score the
final score against Andrew is not
representative of our approximately
equivalent playing strength I think it
depends on the magnets that we're gonna
see you know if it's a Magnus that gets
10 hours of sleep and you know uh sips
on a coffee rather than something else I
I think Magnus is just a force to be
reckoned with I would have to say Andrew
I mean obviously I want to play Magnus
from the perspective of the high that
you get just playing the World Champ the
former world champion uh apologies but
uh from the perspective of my chances of
course I would rather play Andrew and
this is no knock on Andrew he's an
absolute Beast so it's kind of like
choosing between the frying pan and the
fire a little bit
well we know that you'll be you know me
putting the Flames if you don't get on
over to your broadcast meeting because
come on I know what you have to go to
dania will be covering Blitz Champs
Stanford so he won his bullet match he's
going on a happy note but I know you got
to get over there before the team yells
at you so thank you so much yeah that's
starting 5pm Eastern uh if you want to
watch it's a really cool event with
Sanford football players and I'll be
commentating with the long along with
the one and only I am Casa Corley but
Robert Simon thanks again for your
amazing coverage and uh you know my
apologies to Sasha but I'll do my best
to to keep uh keep the legs churning to
borrow a football term
well good luck to you Donya have a good
one we'll watch your show later today
and thanks for dropping by that is
Daniel naroditski always giving us words
of wisdom some anecdotes from his
experiences and just the description he
had of hikaru's play and just overall
tenacity was really awesome to hear and
he moves on to the loser semi-final
where he'll wait the winner of our
upcoming match between Magnus Carlson
and Andrew Tang Simon Donya said with no
offense meant of course to his friend
someone he's played against a lot in
Andrew Tang that would be his preferred
opponent in the semi-finals so that begs
the question what does Andrew have to do
to get through the massive roadblock
that is Magnus Carlson
what are these guys
um Andrew and Magnus they've played so
many times before online I mean they
they fought each other on on occasions
in the middle of the night in the
morning and the day so they know each
other's game much better than anyone
else and it kind of does depend on the
form of both of them you know um
Andrew's had his warm-up match already I
think that will help him you've got to
get into the Zone when you're playing
Magnus Carson you've got to be as near
to 100 as you can possibly be if you're
at 95 percent well that little five
percent against uh Magnus is gonna tell
so it kind of depends on that it depends
on what Andrew turns up but also what
Magnus turns up and you just got to give
it your best shot
um you've got to you know you know what
openings to try out and there's not many
weaknesses in magnus's game the one
thing I would say is just try to attack
him
um I think it's always helpful to get
the initiative in these battles
yeah and what we saw from Magnus against
farrugia is that when it came down to
that final stretch of the game when
Mutual time travel ensued they're in the
scramble farrugia was faster and there
may be no faster player with just a
couple seconds on the clock than Andrew
Tang so Andrew can't afford to be down
15 seconds like he was at times earlier
in the day and in some of the other
matches but I think if Andrew shows that
Top Class speed Magnus will be in
trouble
yeah it's a good point Andrew needs to
play quickly I agree if you've got to
use the clock
um you know the better chess player is
is Magnus so whatever advantages can you
use the clock so get out of the openings
with time advantage and maybe do what
Daniel recommended in his last match
Daniel said he tried to get a 15 20
second advantage and then at two or
three moments in the game tank a little
bit of time uh when it's needed but
speed is going to be something Andrew
will need
another movie reference I appreciate
that and Andrew he does look calm you
know he told us earlier he was honest
that he was nervous but now that he's
playing his Magnus Carlson I feel like
often times you feel like all right
Magnus is the favorite the pressure is
not on me and we'll see if Andrew can
get off to a good start because for
Magnus yesterday against fruja he was
down three games to none and guess what
the final margin was three points and
we're off and it's a king's Gambit
love it I love this choice of opening
already it has given Magnus a very big
Advantage he's in a pawn up with a great
attacking situation and uh I think
Andrew Tang kind of uh he just pre-moved
into this so that that this has worked
fantastically well the extra Pawn is an
extra Central Pawn as well and um you
can attack on the F far so a very crafty
opening Choice that's there Robin
and Andrew he used the pin on the C file
before he could have taken the D4 Pawn
so he had the right idea wrong execution
and now Magnus remains upon to the good
this looks fantastic for him and there's
too much pressure going on the e-file
the queen on E6 is loose the Knight on
D5 will be hanging if you take on E5 and
The Rook picks back hitting the queen
and the Knight beside it so this looks
like a winning advance for Magnus on the
clock and on the board
and you know what I like best
Magnus is singing uh can we can we just
unmute Magnus and hear what he's singing
and we me and Robert can just chill out
and just hear hear the great karaoke
star in his own environment that's
that's what I'd like to see he's got his
headphones on he's tuned in and he's
getting into the vibe here well we might
have to wait for that but this is
something Hikaru does I mean is Magnus
getting tricks mikaru getting his
singing voice out Robert do we think do
we know if Magnus you know can sing a
little bit and he does so many things at
a top level he's the number one Raider
chess player he was the number one in
fantasy football soccer I mean fancy
football is a very American thing so
let's call it soccer and just for ease
but he was number one in the world in
that too so maybe he's secretly a great
singer
come on I mean it's a bit sickening he's
you know he's good he's just too good at
everything he's got to give other people
a chance right I mean you can be world
champion at chess but you're not allowed
to be good at everything so I'm going to
say he's a terrible singer just to make
myself feel better so he has a great
position here right now so whether her
singing is good or not doesn't seem to
be that important and Knight D1 that
turn it around because the queen and the
Rook are both under attack and you can
see I'm magnus's face he's like oh what
was I thinking there
yeah a little bit of overconfidence
there and that has given Andrew
um a good decent well decent position
he's the exchange up five second lead on
the clock though for Magnus and Magnus
position is is quite well I was going to
say quite solid but now Andrew is broken
through on F7 so
um really good fight back from Andrew
oh what a finder he SATs his Queen
temporarily and look at the clock Magnus
is up over 10 seconds he should just
flag his opponent
yes he's got to I mean Andrew's going to
try flagging him enough times in this
and uh not easy to flag though okay oh
look at that Andrew oh no that was sorry
[Laughter]
he stole his Rook because Andrew felt
like he had to pre-move every turn he
and Magus brought his Rook back Magnus
was actually going for a draw there if
the Rooks were traded it would have been
a draw so it's interesting to note that
Magnus maybe not trying to shamelessly
flag his opponent you have to go for the
dirty flag but he was able to get the
job done because of his leading the
clock
it was and he's played the king's Gambit
again uh this time Andrew was expecting
it and we've got a pretty standard
position of the king's Gambit when you
win your Pawn back white has the extra
Central Pawn lots of pieces remain on
the board I love what the white Knights
are doing here jumping straight in uh
but okay the computer really liking the
two Bishops here and there goes one Pawn
so the king's Gambit this is magnus's
secret weapon so far yeah Bobby Fischer
used to love himself a good King's
Gambit and another world champion
decades later Magnus Carlson says I'll
do the same we know he's no longer world
champion Dania also was like wait world
oh sorry excuse me former world champion
Magnus Carlson it's so easy to forget
but oh he just forgot that his Bishop
could be captured so he didn't win the
exchange and did you see his reaction
there
wow that that was just yeah that was a
big mistake you can't make too many
mistakes like that and even though you
say Magnus is not the world champion
always won the queen back there it's all
a bit messy he's kind of like the world
champion in our hearts isn't he he's the
strongest player I think he might isn't
he still rapid world champion on Blitz
World Champion he's world champion or
something I I failed to believe he's not
and um the reason why you didn't
remember which one is because the answer
is both and he also just won this third
game in a row so he can't stop won't
stop winning
yeah of course thing is the world
champion we know this and a very well
deserved world champion he is but uh
kind of due to Magnus not taking part
isn't it as well I'd love to see ding
play Magnus at a future moment hopefully
that will happen
uh but Magnus is the speed world
champion
okay so he's got a nice lead uh a
massive lead is there any way that uh
Andrew can come back from us
um yes definitely like in the overall
match I definitely believe you hesitate
it you hesitated the reason is because I
thought you were asking me about this
specific game and you know I look at
this position and this looks like a
king's Indian gone completely wrong for
white and looking great for black and
you see the capture on G4 leaves the E4
Pawn hanging this is a dream come true
for Magnus
yeah this is a beautiful position
completely uh completely agree if you
look at Black's pawns piling through and
um the white king incredibly exposed
here at the same time I mean still just
about hanging on but that F Pawn is uh
getting very close to becoming a queen
as well
um
queens of the board still hanging on
there's a nasty fret of Rook swinging
over in some positions here as well
I don't think there's anything that can
be done and another win for Magnus he
seems to be on good form
remember in good form when ferrugia said
that Magnus needed to level up I think
Magnus is officially leveled up like
this is
ridiculous thus far four straight wins
and convincing ones at that leading on
the clock throughout most of the games
he's hasn't been worse in his positions
very often and now he goes to a setup
where he has his Bishops both fianchetto
and now the board's opening up for those
very Bishops Advantage magnets they're
ever so slight Advantage but still I
like the bishop pair
yeah the Bishops are looking quite good
now and he's got he's swapped one
advantage of Bishop paired to a better
Pawn structure now and the reason this
is a better Pawn structure is Black's
pawns are rigid in the middle and that
one there the Magnus is attacking is
very weak the one on D5 so it's very
subtle advantages and one thing that is
clear about Magnus is his will I mean to
be a champion like he is it's not just
about your talent the amount of work you
put in you've got to have the an amazing
will and you want to win everything and
that will to win is gonna you know after
he lost to faruga it's gonna be shown
um in these upcoming matches and I would
not like to play an angry Madness oh he
he wants some kind of like he might go
king of one at some point oh just Rock
drop he drops his Rook wow he's
blundered a rook after I say that
and Andrew gets that win uh but I think
what you're saying is true because when
he beat Eric he was upset that he'd give
Eric any points he wants to win every
single game he plays he has you know the
heart of a champion but also he's got
the hunger of a lion he really wants to
win every single game that he puts I
don't even know if lions are that hungry
like can someone who actually knows
about animals tell us are lion just
seems like kings of the Jungle or are
they actually also hungry all the time
because Hungry Hungry Hippos was a game
I never played hungry hungry lions
I reckon lions are hungry they're going
to be they're big they're big they're
big cats aren't they and I'll tell you
one thing my cat is always hungry always
eating far too much
um so they've got to be they've got to
be hungry
um and I love the way we we sometimes
progress away from the chest it's nice
to have a little break because I get a
headache otherwise with the amazing play
on the board and this is so complicated
this position uh I mean the white king
looks really exposed but white is a
piece up
any result possible here yeah I thought
there would be almost a Checkmate but
the knights are protected and there it
looks like a pin down the C file but
there's a light Square Bishop in the way
but Simon clock and King safety both in
Black's favor and Rook C4 picks up not
the D4 square but this Knight on e4
yeah and this is the thing even though
uh White was probably winning somewhere
if you have the initiative it counts for
so much at this time limit and now it's
equal issue material and that white king
is getting absolutely teared apart here
and uh I doubt it can survive is there a
killer blow just taking the Rook all of
a sudden Magnus is a whole Rook up
did you see them the way you played that
one check that wasn't even just like oh
I'm gonna try to flag my opponent that
was the best move so Magnus I mean he
really is in charge of the match right
now
yes just dominating the match at the
moment I mean when Magnus plays like
this
there's not many people who have a
chance
um against him
Andrew's gotta pick up his game he's got
to get some wins on the board there is
20 minutes to go often these matches go
in swings but another strong tactic
there from Magnus Knight C6 and this is
simply going up a whole rook and he won
that game in a matter of seconds
phenomenal play and I love this comment
from fractured Soul this is like
watching Messi play Simply Sublime and
as an American welcoming Messi to the
Emma lesson into Miami that should be
fun but yeah watching Messi played
throughout his career has been a treat
for everybody and watching Magnus when
he's informed it's a treat for everybody
except for his opponents because I don't
think Andrew's having the best time thus
far
no I mean it's not enjoyable when anyone
tries to smash you but look at that that
is a beautiful move from Andrew
absolutely stunning Vision I love that
the whole point is the white Bishop can
check the black king and then it can
pick up the the queen in the middle
Magnus counter strikes now so you have
to be a little bit careful and Andrew
spending his time but that just shows uh
how strong Andrew can be and how quickly
he also spots tactics oh Andrew Tang is
world class and I think when we are
looking at this match we will always
acknowledge that and Magnus just happens
to have jumped out to a hot start and
he's trying to run away with his King so
considering he lost his Queen but he
lost it for a night and a rook he does
have compensation he's worse and now
he's gonna drop another Pawn in the
center but I'm looking at the clock and
maybe black is even better because of
the time
yeah it's true and the Black Knight has
now secured itself in the middle of the
board and uh the only way that white can
probably win this is by using that past
Pawn which he has shoved up the board
uh but the clock will be important if
there's anyone else I'd be backing black
but Andrew is pretty well known for his
speed and that should secure the game
nice that was a brilliant win from
Andrew we need more of that he's got a
nice point on the board and let's see if
he can uh keep get a roll going he needs
to get a role going now
and point very well taken that Andrew
you know when he has even a Time deficit
how quickly he plays it's a sight to
behold and he was able to win that game
he kept enough time on the clock and
found the killer blow and in this game
Magnus just kind of playing this slowly
he's giving away a pawn to open up some
lines and Bishop takes D6 Queen takes
c66 to follow the E6 Pawn will be tender
I think Andrew did the right thing being
brave uh yeah you're right though this
is the oh lovely oh nearly it was close
I'm just shocked at all moments when
moves like that happen like here's the
queen A4 I wasn't even looking in that
direction I was looking along the C file
and well Andrew's done well to hold on
here the Knight takes F5 that's a good
shot from Magnus but
what in the world of an opposite color
Bishop Rook end game where White's Pawn
structure is better
yeah yeah I mean that again it's going
so so quickly I mean white is better
here because White's got the potential
to get a past Pawn so you see the pawn
on the right hand side uh okay it's
still a little bit better for white but
should be a draw there goes the past
Pawn
gonna come down to the clock like extra
extra lot of time for Magus but I I feel
that 50 moves should better should be
made here in time yeah yeah
and they actually repeated the position
three times and I was going to say if
the colors were reversed I think Andrew
may be able to get that job done and
flag Magnus but their moves were so easy
to play just move your king back and
forth and so it pre-moves were available
and now in this game we get a London
system Andrew Tang's specialty and so
far looks pretty normal I think black
has escaped the opening without any
disadvantage whatsoever
yep
and here comes the black pawns moving
down the board
uh I mean that's the other thing about
you know um I would say like uh
Grandmaster I don't mean that with any
disrespect but not a world champion and
uh Andrew is nothing he's not a regular
Master that's the wrong thing to say but
someone who hasn't played in World
Championship matches magnus's openings
are just so good because he's prepared
for so many of these big encounters with
a team behind him and he's able to swap
in and out of certain openings and he
should be okay in most positions I I say
that though he is playing 186 quite a
lot in this match
um which is a very peculiar opening to
play and here is black attacking again
Robert
it looks like that to my eyes but Andrew
is stopping that attack by playing in
the center that's often how you combat
somebody who's going after your king and
I just want to quickly follow up what
you're saying that as regular
Grandmasters ourselves no I think we we
know what you mean that our opening
preparation oh gosh that's a blunder of
an exchange there on E3 but even though
some games some openings oh there's a
mouse slip by Magnus and he gets away
with it because Andrew was pre-moving
and a little smile out of Andrew but we
get away with things in individual games
some moments winnings but on the whole
people who played the candidates in the
world champion matches their opening
preparation is much deeper and better
and Magnus he's looking to pick up this
game with the black pieces he's a rook
against a bishop those past pawns are
stopped Simon this looks like a win for
Black based on how much time remains
yes another Point
um just just racking them up at the
moment even after a mouse slip there uh
yeah I mean it's just a show of class at
the moment and the way that Magnus is
playing
he loves having the two Bishops as well
magnus's little things in his games you
will see happen time and time again and
uh I I think maybe the stronger you get
as a player the more you appreciate
having the two Bishops that's why I like
having the knights because I find them
trickier and here you can see those
Bishops working very well to win The
Exchange
black has some attacking chances here
though and what Magnus just Blended a
bishop on F5 with check yeah he is not
gonna happen and H6 is an important move
because Queen takes B4 there are back
ranked threats so right now Andrew isn't
charged in this game on the board and on
the clock but finding The Knockout not
so easy here because if the Queens come
off the board winning from there will be
far from simple
yeah
uh you've got to win this one the white
king very weak get your dark Square
Bishop maybe G6 is a move here or G5
that would be quite uh maybe it doesn't
work so well now getting on the dark
squares I agree with what you said about
keeping the Queens on when you've got
the Knight and Bishop versus The Rook
you want to keep the Queens on the board
generally because they're great
attackers and I think now it will be
Magnus resigning and he does because the
queen was about to check White's King
and uh it's just too exposed there and
we gotta just resign from Simon and you
were a spot on Simon Says and it happens
and this kind of position I feel like is
nice in bullet the one we're seeing from
the white side here A7 just dropped so
Magnus didn't take care of his a pawn
and now it's off the board and the
advantage very heavily in Andrew Tank's
favor in this game
it is but look at that a file I mean oh
straight in with a tactic does that work
or does it Bluff another thing I've
noticed is that Magnus does bluff
occasionally you know when things go a
little bit wrong he will play a quick
move confidence and because he's Magnus
Carson his opponents won't always take
you know capitalize on that
yeah you believe the former world
champion and the number one reader
player in the world for such a long time
now I think that I believe that Andrew
will win this game as he is two nights
for a rook in the position he's about to
gobble up the queenside pawn and now his
passer just runs
there's still a chance I mean it's not
all over it's seven and a half to three
and a half uh there's 12 minutes left
Andrew is now getting into a bit of a
rhythm uh he's playing really well uh to
you know just to get points on the board
against this uh this you know
horrendously strong player and if he
wins this one well you know it's still
doable still possible
needs to win this one because Magnus is
trying to catch up on the clock but
finally The Rook cylinder attack the G6
Pawn the B6 Pawn is passed so that was a
resignation Andrew gets it it's a
three-point deficit now and Magus he
shows that hey there are times where he
missteps and Angela was able to scoop up
that Bishop on F5 with check and then
win the game
yep important window is getting a bit
more into the match now Andrew his
confidence is growing and you need to
have that
um in this one we see Magnus playing
with a knight instead of the bishop
but he has a nice compact Pawn structure
no weaknesses in White's position and
maybe Black's pawns are even a little
bit overextended there you go one Pawn
drops and there could be some more
exchanges here but is that a pawn gonna
drop it does drop so a pawn up for
Magnus clean pawn and this King on G1 if
queens were on the board we said maybe
black can get an attack on the light
squares but without Queens on the board
there's no checkmating threats and F3
stops all that before I can even finish
my sentence about it
and the next stage here would be able to
oh he just he just blundered there oh
the mouse slip
Four Points in it
yeah
Mouse lips they happen especially in
bullet we saw Dania drop his Queen in
front of a bishop and lose that earlier
because of a mouse slip so none of these
players they're it's not a foreign
concept to them but probably a moment
that Angela can I Mouse slip later today
not in my master it's Magnus Carlsen
yeah
he was mouth slip when it's the worst
possible time as well I found you know
you don't Mouse slip and like move one
where it doesn't matter it's always when
you're you're winning and you drop a
queen
um and here well again look at Black's
pieces black has won a one a piece with
that PIN and the black king is very safe
so there's not really any compensation
and that's why Andrew resides just to
get on with the next game I love the use
of the Kings Gambit I I play the king
I'm one of the only Grand Masters who
still plays it you mentioned Bobby
Fischer playing the Kings game I think
the most famous world champion was Boris
spaski he won every single game he
played in the Kings play these openings
still even at the top level
yeah I mean Magnus and ikaru also he
dabbles with the king's Gambit and
played it for a long time but this is
terrible this is why you don't play the
Kings Gambit is because the king is
still in the center and black is happily
up a pawn and you could probably just
start taking things and the Knight on e4
is in trouble this is just game over
it should be yeah um Bishop G6 a class
move yeah it is it is game over Robert
you're right and uh a nice little touch
shirt Ian really good play from Andrew
he's he's spotting uh spotting the
tactics there very quickly
is now a clean exchange with the safer
King and Magnus he shouldn't resign and
he's digging a drink of water he'll
probably let his time elapse look at how
much time is left in this match eight
minutes and now about to be 40 seconds
he didn't resign as soon as I said that
he resigned
he could have let that time go
he is super confident uh Robert you know
I mean he he he just wants to win more
games he he's he's confident in his
ability uh he's thinking I don't need to
do any of these tactics I'm just gonna
win more games and I want to know what
he's singing at least we've got a
question for the interview right uh what
music is he listening to and what's he
singing anyone got any predictions in
the chat oh you know Magna say he's
listening to you know you're asking for
it Simon by getting the chat involved
about what he's listening to we're even
got some funny answers yeah but I am
actually curious yeah different we heard
Bortnick say he likes to listen to rock
music and just different whatever he's
vibing to at the moment but right now
Magnus in this game up and outside Pawn
King very safe the e-pawn advances and
those hanging Pawns in the center they
can be strengths if you can get them
going and they take away squares from
enemy pieces but they can also be
dangling and weaknesses
yeah and this is weird there's too many
nights in this position for me to better
work out what's happening but there goes
the exchange uh even though the exchange
has gone Black's nice they're holding a
lot of squares
very good play so far from there there
it goes um Andrew wins another one so
he's keeping himself just about in the
match and Magnus was really unhappy
about that I see that Michael Jackson uh
shout out there Guardians of the Galaxy
music
see I you told you you just get
ridiculous answers
yeah I know I was asking for it as you
said there Robert a little bit too much
wasn't I say I was gonna set myself up
Barbie girl I've seen he's there he's
listening to his stream that's a really
good answer but if I die
5D
okay we see him in this game using
tactics a little bit more
um and
uh just to run the clock down now the
six minutes 46. and the score is free in
it so okay Andrew needs to win a game or
two to make this make this uh
interesting and no more love this
opening yeah no more this is this
I'll say no more King's Gambit but he
sacked a piece this is your style
this is actually supposed to be pretty
good for white and I I was thinking why
did why did in the previous match uh
this wasn't tried out because G6 is a
little mistake A3 actually sets up G6
and the sacrifice it's kind of a very
weird delayed Halloween Gambit idea
um and now it's equal material and
there's a big check with the Knight
misplacing Black's King but this also
looks like a decent way to play Black's
pawns are are horribly uh distorted here
I would also love what Magnus did there
he just lost the advantage by his
follow-up decisions but instead of going
for a Checkmate or a check that may not
have mounted too much he just ruined his
opponent's Pawn structure but Andrew now
if you push this Pawn to C3 then the
queen comes into A2 and you're just
going for checkmate Queen into still a
great move the C2 Pawn is loose this
looks residable
yeah this is this is a chance and it's
only gonna be two points in it this is
where even if you are Magnus Carson you
start to get a little bit nervous you
don't want to lose this big lead and uh
you can see I think he he swore a little
bit there he's let his time go down he's
readjusting Andrew has a chance he's
back in the match there's five minutes
to go remember you need to win by two
points and if Andrew takes the next one
well it's game on
I'll be cutting it to one and now you
see no more 1a6 uh he stopped probably
gonna stop playing the king's Gambit
going forward uh Magnus is not like this
is getting too close for comfort now I
need to give my full focus and play more
Mainline stuff and I don't think Andrew
knows this line nearly as well as Magnus
does
nice very hard to know the highest as
well as uh you know Magnus he has his
team of workers and this this is a very
interesting idea and if black can stop
white from castling it could be a
disaster
and yeah he puts pressure on that night
so if White Castles he catches it and
now white can't Castle so White's King
is walking a tightrope but what happened
there the Magnus blunder a piece uh I
think he just wanted he just lost a
piece his night was under attack
uh or you know the PCB Fork Studio was
the under attack against didn't move it
that was strange
look at his face Robert oh if if Andrew
can keep this together which oh no it's
getting messy
Rook B one oh
he's fought back into the match
white is completely tied up here
wow this is a big big game Robert I feel
it is yeah because if Andrew won it
would be a one point match but now
Magnus he's head bobbing he's trading
pieces if he wants to he's also up over
20 seconds
yeah this is a massive game because the
difference for this one was as you said
it could be one point in the match or
three if Magnus wins and Magnus wins to
take it to three points meaning that and
look at him he gives a little laugh
there realizing he's very lucky meaning
that Andrew must win this game now with
the black pieces and maybe the next game
as well I mean this is this is a must
win scenario isn't it this game he needs
to win this one and he needs to win the
next one and he doesn't have a choice in
the matter so uh from the black side of
this position it looks like the pawn
structure not particularly good for
either side but the C7 C6 Pawn is harder
to get to that pawn on F3 in particular
down the road that could be a real
weakness that white has to defend
yeah and I love what uh Black's done
with the Knight there the night finder
great Square Rook takes Knight is a
threat
it's a Magnus sacrifices first here
and
black has chances in this one chances to
get that important win which he must win
yes but the f file that's going to give
black a lot of the action of the Knight
on D3 that is one of the best place
pieces you could possibly ask for
yeah and those two pawns also Robert
they're coming through the board aren't
they I mean uh two connected pass pawns
very scary here and
The Rook now has to give way to the H
Pawn with okay maybe maybe that could
have been played better yeah what a fine
though King G6 but now Knight F4 kicks
the king away H7 Falls and oh it doesn't
make 96 rookie seven
I think that could be it
you can see Andrew shaking his head
there there's only two minutes left and
uh yeah Magnus giving a little cheer
there he realizes he's through and maybe
a little sigh of relief
I was gonna say the same thing that
you're about to say so please finish
Simon
I I was gonna I just think I was gonna
say I don't think Magnus be 100 happy to
win a match when but I don't know it's
sort of hasn't been that clean
and I think that's why he celebrated
because if he was going to win this
match by a large margin but yeah okay
another day at the office but the fact
that Andrew gave him a serious fight and
there were some odd blunders and things
of that nature you know even in bullet
odd for Magnus I think that you know he
felt like he was on some rocky uh
terrain and well even in this game like
he was doing just fine and suddenly he's
dropped upon an end game and his Pawn
structure is bad so it has not been a
perfect performance by any stretch of
the imagination but that's who Magnus is
even when he's not playing perfectly
he's still beating stars like Andrew
Tang by several points
yeah I I mean he's done what he's done
enough I think in this one but
he needs to play better than this if
he's going to beat Hikaru I would say uh
you know if we do see a Magnus Carson
Hikaru final I think Magnus would have
played a little bit better because
hikara is just not going to show any
Mercy
and he'll have to play better on this to
beat Dania tomorrow right this yes the
way he's played in this match I mean
Dania beat Andrew tank by eight points
and of course things change day to day
and match by match uh but the way
Donnie's been playing in this event I
really think that Magnus will have to
improve his play and well I don't know
if this last game maybe it's often time
it doesn't change the match Victor that
is magnet so yeah this game has
concluded they stopped it and Magnus is
like why I'll play another one
yeah
I mean uh yeah okay well Andrew's
resigned that one realizing there's no
point it's not going to affect the match
at all and we see Magnus winning that
one
um and you've got a little bit closer
one moment but I the the stronger player
did win uh throughout that match uh
Magnus was always ahead and uh yeah
pretty pretty good performance sir yeah
pretty good five point win over Andrew
tang and it's going to be scary for
opponents when he loves up even more
from pretty good to his best so Magnus
Carlson he wins the match against Andrew
Tang he stays alive in this bullet Chess
Championship he will face Daniel
neraditski so Magnus has insured himself
a top four ranking and we will surely
get him in for an interview so uh we I
believe are going to head for a quick
break after we look at the bracket where
and as we look at the bracket
um we see that mag
Magnus is playing against Daniel
naroditski
and that is in the loser semi-final but
up later today is Hikaru against alireza
faruza in the winners final that's our
last match of the day Simon
yeah what a match that's going to be I
mean we've just seen uh you know the
strongest chess player in all formats
against
um I guess you could argue the strongest
player in online bullets and um that is
going to be a brilliant match as well
isn't it I mean Hikaru it's always good
watching Hikaru play Magnus Frodo to the
next round uh so we can be happy about
that I mean it was uh interesting match
I also saw that Magnus has had a haircut
sometimes you've got to you know just
reinvent yourself uh I I always got in
the habit Robert of having a bit of a
haircut before I played a chess
tournament because it made me feel that
little bit more confident I wouldn't
touch the beard though the beer can just
go and do it straggly thing the bid's
got to stay but sometimes a little bit
of a haircut does help I think and uh
you know new haircut new person
well the beard is majestic new haircut
new person new scenery new person
because Magnus is actually on the go
he's not gonna get an interview he has
to catch his cab so we're gonna head to
break but when returned it is in fact
there is a fuja you will not want to
miss that
have a friend or family member who loves
chess give them a chess.com membership
today and see them take their game to
the next level
can choose a gold platinum or Diamond
membership for one month or one year
want your gift to arrive on your
friend's birthday or on a holiday gifts
can be scheduled to arrive up to 90 days
in the future
all premium plans include an ad-free
experience unlimited puzzles and lessons
and unlock all Bots go platinum to add
unlimited game review or Diamond to
unlock insights and Coach explanations
give the gift of Chess today
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock app right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time Lots yeah okay you bring the clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get somebody okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the fork he's good man he's good
he can take on D5 with check and the
problem is now he has a dramatic attack
he's got to turn the game around he's
just giving up his bishop and he's
giving what's going on here Bible
captured and he's getting mated
thinking about winning when he's losing
and then he's going to demoralize you
when he does that Andrew quickly winning
a couple games in a row that
is really important for him oh my gosh
he allowed a Checkmate as soon as I said
winning a couple games
gets it done again just reminds us uh
Robert Wise on top of the bullet world
[Music]
you're a three-time bullet chess
champion the biggest chess streamer on
the planet the number two rated player
in the world in classical chess that is
a card Nakamura in the winners finals
taking on alireza faruja and what we
just saw there is his resourcefulness
his tenacity his ability to turn games
around
yeah 100 Robert
um Hikaru is just good at everything uh
in bullet he can play the openings
incredibly well Daniel mentioned how he
he picks the openings of certain
opponents and you can uh tune into their
weaknesses uh he can play positional
chess incredibly well endings well
tactics amazing if he gets an advantage
he doesn't let the advantage slip and he
also creates major problems when he's in
a worse position he's pretty good at
everything I mean that's just everything
Robert how'd you beat him how can you
beat Hikaru I don't have the answers so
I think we'll have to wait and see if
Ali Reza for ruja does because that is
our matchup starting in just under 10
minutes for ruja originally from Iran
now playing for France uh he is really
really really good at bullet himself and
we've heard his confidence Peru just
saying I didn't feel like I was an
underdog against Magnus he wasn't the
favorite against me and I think that he
feels that Hikaru isn't much of a
favorite either
yep he's full of confidence he's young
he's quick he's an amazing attacker and
he's dangerous at everyone he's got lots
of experience in bullet chess and um
he's been tipped by so many people as
being a future world champion uh as well
he's basically the whole package and I
think this is one match that everyone
can be really excited for I mean what
better way to continue his streak you
beat Magnus Carson or you know one day
and you face Hikaru the next day if you
beat Hikaru and it's like yeah okay I'm
the daddy who's the daddy I'm the daddy
and uh it's now time for furusia to try
and prove that he's the daddy
sorry will he be the daddy am I saying
Daddy too much you know I'm not gonna
judge you for it but you called out that
he beat Magnus yesterday so why not
Hikaru today and that's the type of
event that alireza fuja wants to
continue having because you look up in
the winners final it's farrugia it's
Nakamura alireza took down Magnus
Carlson it was Hikaru taking down Daniel
naroditsky and the loser of this match
the good news for them is that they're
not eliminated they just go down to the
loser's final where they await the
winner of Donya versus Magna so we're at
our final four and alireza farouza he
doesn't want to be the person floating
down to the loser's bracket and having
to work his way back up this is a
determined kid is he still a kid he's
like 20 years old now but it still feels
like a kid because he is one of the
game's great prodigies he was personally
selected hand-picked by Magnus Carlsen
saying I would only play him if I was
going to compete for the World Chess
Championship Al Reza he floundered in
the candidates tournament as he leaves
his chair there he actually was playing
a lot of bullet when things weren't
going his Way Dania and alireza played a
long match during the candidates that
was much talked about but ferusia he's
proven himself in this time control he
won the 2021 bullet Chess Championship
it's his fifth appearance he's Peak
rating 35 21.
incredible player I mean both of these
players are just incredible
um we've mentioned a lot about farrugia
and how Magnus hand-picked him that
Ruger had one that candidates tournament
Magnus would have played the world
championships and being hand-picked by
Magnus Carlson is is quite special uh I
think the other thing that we should
note though is that pressure uh upon
your shoulders right if you're if you
are Ali Razer faruca and you're being
picked by the world champion everyone's
saying oh you're going to be the next
World Champion it can make you crumble
right
um You can you know it's it's just too
much pressure for most people to be able
to handle that you you have to be quite
special and I did Rachel he he's shown
that he can handle that and that he's
got a very good confidence about him and
he's gonna need to have that confidence
to take down uh Hikaru today so this is
probably the match I've been most
excited about so far Robert I mean uh
you can't get more excited than this
match can you I don't think so because
not only is it these two powerhouses but
there's so much on the line neither
player wants to drop the losers bracket
as we're talking about so the
elimination that's not going to happen
to either player here but the winner is
guaranteed minimum 16
000 and a top two final placement
whereas the loser drops down to the
loser's final you know minimum third
place but 16k for the winner uh is
guaranteed that's quite a chunk of
change
it's not bad that will certainly help
Ali rage to start his fashion career
um and you know which uh I wonder we
have to ask him about that if we get to
an interview stage but it's a big big
goal on offer here I mean you win this
you've you know you go through in a very
comfortable position with a great deal
of money as well so it's gonna be a big
match and another thing we should
mention is
um this match is longer and then the
other matches I think it's 45 minutes
that they play for previous to this all
matches have been 30 minutes and that I
guess means it favors the stronger
player I'm not even sure who the
stronger plays I guess we've got to go
for Hikaru but both of these players
have won this competition before because
it means the variance is less when you
have more time
um do we think that's going to favor
hikara or is it just too hard to say
brother it's so hard to distinguish
between these two players because Hikaru
has three titles to his name that gives
him the nine but oh there is a beat
Hikaru when he went on his path to the
championship as you see on this graphic
in front of you that not only is Hikaru
a speed demon he's the number one
classical rated American he's number two
in the world I think that might be the
more important number uh to his name
because he and Fabiano are separated by
just a few rating points for the top
American spot and for number two behind
Magnus Carlson he's the reign three-time
bullet Champion reigning five-time
speeches champion and the number of
subscribers on YouTube it goes up and up
and away over 2 million at this point in
addition to all of the followers he has
on Twitch so he was the top seed as the
reigning Champion but you know for
Hikaru he's streaming now he is doing
this live in front of his audience uh
you know he doesn't need to prove
anything to anybody he's been Elite for
a long time now but it feels like he's
never ever stops trying he always wants
to win and for farooza he's the younger
of the two and his career his full
career is ahead of him
that's right yeah
um I mean I don't think either of these
players have much to prove really but uh
to get to their situation they're
they're kind of born Champions so they
just want to win uh there's you know
they've got that side to them where
nothing else matters except for winning
so they're both going to be fighting
very hard I mean don't I don't believe
Hikaru fully when it says you know the
chess creator doesn't matter he's just a
streamer yeah uh that sounds like a bit
of a cover to me it maybe takes a bit of
pressure off him he is the world's most
famous chess streamer
um he's done brilliantly from that but
he's an amazing chess player he's number
two in the world in classical chess he
is incredibly strong at all parts of the
game so uh I don't know he's not just a
streamer is he Robert I mean he can do
other things well as well you can move
the pieces occasionally yeah there's
this variant I forgot what's called me
Fisher random and I think Hikaru did
yeah he did okay in that event yeah he's
the Fisher random world Champion so he
keeps racking up the titles title
Tuesday it feels like he's winning maybe
every other one at this stage it's just
incredible the number of tournament
victories uh he has the trophies on his
mantle but otherwise The Frugal so he's
the younger of the two and he doesn't
have as many tournament wins but what I
was impressed by after the Candace the
candidates did not go well for alireza
they were probably a disappointment for
him and his team but then he rebounded
by tying for first and ultimately
winning the sinkfield cup and the grand
chess tour so that rebound that ability
to come back after having some
disappointment and frustration instead
of just throwing in the towel he's like
you know what that just makes me want to
work harder
yeah I I mean what's that favorite
expression Robert it's not how you fall
down it's how you get up and we're all
gonna have we'll have knocks in our
lives and we just got to get up and
prove that we're stronger from them and
that's the sign of a real Champion right
to take the punch in the face but get up
stronger after that punch or whatever
knock you get and uh we're getting very
close to the match now I think yeah and
we have an empty chair on camera as
Hikaru left but he will be right back to
start this match and for farugia he
wants this you know he does uh he I like
the confidence because I don't think
it's a false confidence when he said
that I didn't feel like the underdog
against Magnus he proved that he
probably wasn't and now against Hikaru
alireza has beaten ikar before and by
the way their ratings if I'm seeing this
correctly alireza 33 23 Hikaru 33 39 at
the moment so only 16 rating points as
they're both above 3 300 in chess
yeah that number's just too high for me
I'm not even sure what that means
anymore it's not it's just astronomical
but there are it shows that they're just
very closely matched and we have some
moves we are starting and we're starting
with Hikaru on the white side of one of
his favorite openings and alireza going
for a king's Indian defense setup yeah
and look at this punching connect five
for a weight Connect Four for black and
you typically attack in the direction of
your Pawn chain so Black's punching is
heading towards the king side I really
like this for faruga as you know white
finally strikes with E4 if a knight gets
it D6 maybe you have some compensation
but at the first glance I think that
Black's Mission looks very healthy
yeah I agree as well I mean if you
compare the Bishops white start Square
Bishop is trapped behind that pawn and
black start Square Bishop is pointing at
that pawn in the middle and the the
Black Knight has potential to swing its
way in and uh I think these first couple
of games are so important because you
can relax a little bit you can't really
ever relax but you can slightly relax if
you get a lead and look at that black
winning an important Pony can win
another Pawn here but the B Pawn is
quite weak still very complexes this
position yeah isn't C5 about to drop and
then B6 but Hikaru recognizes it's not
just about to pass on this end game
should be level and I think at this
stage with limited material the Knight
will sacrifice to solve for one pawn and
that's the only Pawn remaining that
should just make a drop
solid start from both players good save
from hikara there look like Navi razor
was pushing a little bit interesting to
see what openings they both decide upon
and we had a Berlin here so Hikaru
showing that he wants to go solid
against his younger opponents and hikara
knows this Berlin very well from the
black side he goes for the bishop and
Knight takes E5 a tactic on F7 and the
H5 Knight is hanging so well spotted by
farugia a bit of a careless move by
Hikaru that's what happens when you're
playing instantly clear Advantage for
ruja in this game
yeah it seems like a pretty safe Pawn or
two that white has taken he's just got
against night out though this is a a key
thing you know if that white knight is
not able to develop it could be trouble
even in the ending Hikaru now annoying
that night but white has the lead can't
shouldn't lose this this game with the
extra Pawn but there goes one Pawn a
little bit of danger here yeah one Pawn
down for black but seven seconds up but
that's peace that is the game
nice win there from
Borussia yes and um
you could see a car on a delay by the
way like he's streaming so the camera is
coming in a delay because his reaction
was several seconds after he blundered
that piece
yeah
good start so far I mean there's a long
way to go remember it's a 45 minute
match
and
into the next game quickly
nice tattoo there showing a tactic
yeah double X lamb you were seeing it
first the E6 Pawn was hanging uh too
many pieces loose and the King on G8
would be in check
yeah and he he car is just working out
if you can go Bishop takes Knight there
but this is a safer way of doing it
[Music]
um
and but here what's happening the
evaluation bar suddenly liking was
liking black there for a second and this
bishop these black bishops are are
creating a lot of counter play yeah so
what is it an extra Pawn for a white but
a pair of Bishops for black I like the
extra material I feel in bullet it's
good to give your opponent double pawns
it's good to steal a pawn even if it's a
Gambit you know if it loses don't take
the pawn but I think for the most we're
proving that compensation is very
difficult in quick chess
yep not much material on the board here
so probably a draw is the most likely if
we look at the time situation though or
that's a big Advantage for me Cara who
is 10 seconds up on the clock and um
that is something which is going to tell
uh in in these endings and we're seeing
pawns get traded opposite colored
Bishops I think Hikaru should try to
flag alireza here the moves aren't
always going to be removable for black
especially after F5 now you got to get
your Bishop back but this is not an easy
end game in fact isn't white no it's not
winning because of the corner brilliant
awareness from Hikaru steal the A4 Pawn
bring your King backwards take the pawn
make a pawn move at some moment alireza
is going to fly
oh this is horrible because this is a
drawn position even though white is four
points up you cannot promote your
opponent to a queen because of stalemate
so you just win on time and that is
painful losing like that that's only
happens in bullet chess but it is of
course part of the game part of the
process
um I mean winning like that it's a bit
sadistic but you've got to be sadistic
if you want to be a top chess player
again if you want to win the ball of
Chess Championship you simply must we
say it every day do not have shame in
flagging your opponent it's not even a
dirty flag it's part of the game if
you're playing with one minute to start
with if you wanted to play Stellar chess
perfect chess you're not going to be
playing bullet chess so it's good to see
how they work in the scrambles Hikaru
too much extra time for farooza to deal
with and in this game hikarus King looks
wide open whereas the King on G1 looks
very very safe
it does one and a half all and I think
this is how the match is going to go
it's gonna go Blue for blue King safety
as you pointed out Robert is is one of
the key things and this last move is
attacking the poor maybe white can just
grab that pawn he does but the black
king is so exposed here compared to the
white king the white king just tucked
away uh safely on G1
it's just you know tucked in I got a
blanket above it and oh Queen D3 double
attack
beautiful move there attacking the
Knight and the bishop in the middle
great awareness all right from Ali razor
yeah blanket up that King and Ali razor
now goes up a point as well looking he's
looking very good at the moment Ali
razor Robert
and 70 of the chat predicted Hikaru
would win this match so it's still
anyone's match very early on 38 minutes
remaining uh in this one so yeah we
don't know who's gonna win but 70
thought it'd be Hikaru and I think 70
would say Hikaru should be the favorite
in this specific game because that
Bishop 185 looks pretty trapped to my
eyes
yeah there's no way out for that Bishop
okay but he's found and where you can
get it into D4 there's also Knight G4
here though it was an interesting idea
but okay
the Knight on D1 stops that idea I guess
and
ikaru finding some precise defensive
moves here
to convert that extra piece
any Razer fighting a little bit but
they are so accurate I mean that that's
what makes these players sort of Stand
Out Robert I feel like how how they just
blunder less they make less mistakes
they take their chances when they give
them to them
and just great moves one after another
and we see a queen trade Bishop D4 he
could have just taken on A7 he plays
with Bishop D4 and now we're seeing
liquidation and white is simply up a
piece there might be a bishop E8 to G6
with a rookie mate that's probably what
I would try to aim for like right now
and that's what's gonna happen in this
one
yeah nice way to finish it and
Hikaru thinking a little bit there okay
uh what just happened so many pawns just
went off the board
I must admit Robert after commentating
this for a couple of hours now sometimes
my brain just goes to Mush so I don't
know how the players do it you know and
this is this is not clear at all can
really not clicks that pawn is on pre
but look at the time it's me look at the
time ruggage she was me and so Oliver
wins that game are you kidding me what
I didn't even realize he won that game
I mean from the start of that Hikaru was
up a piece making all these good moves
and then suddenly several blunders in a
row happened and Alvarez had just enough
time to deliver the knockout
that was incredible I mean you could see
it on hikaru's face there he's shaking
his head and this is dangerous territory
fakara it was a bit too quick for me
I'll be honest and uh somehow Ali Razer
won that game taking a two-point lead
and the reason it's dangerous is a loss
like that can affect you
um you you can start doubting yourself
and it can give your opponent strength
as well
breaking in the center here I mean they
made a knight F6 yeah sorry brother no
no no no no no yeah we are you know we
have the same mind I think it still
should work some kind of Knight F6 check
with Queen G4 to follow the black king
has no defenders in alireza he spots it
the second time
yeah this move just just opens up the
black king and maybe not oh it is it's
just winning it's crushing and look Ali
razor that is the danger you go until
you hardly ever see Hikaru lose three
games in a row Ali razor is just tearing
through him at the moment yeah and you
cannot let those opportunities go by
like Hikaru did when he was up a piece
and now Karo he should be up at peace
again because that Bishop on C5 oh wow
what is actually save there uh from oh
there is he makes Space versus Bishop on
the diagonal but the very least he cars
doesn't go up a pawn and
I feel like this is something hit cars
as often that Perfection is often the
enemy of the good and he says that with
respect to Bullet chess because when you
start spending all of his time trying to
find the objectively best move every
single turn you end up down six seconds
and you may not have enough time to
convert your advantage
interesting point that yeah I mean you
know in classical chess you try to play
perfect and you try to spend your time
doing the right thing but in budget
chess you you obviously can't do that
you just got to go over your instincts
you've got to play practical moves
sometimes rather than the best moves and
uh that's that's something which you
gotta master
uh people I've seen in the in in the
chat saying this is not chess well it is
chess it's just a different form of
Chess it's chess is chess on some you
know on steroids basically
steroid chest which is you know
hey still chess right you know Barry
Barnes sort of done steroids still was a
baseball player
it's still chess and it's just a zoomed
up version what What's Happening Here it
looked like Hikaru is winning but he's
he's
is he gonna throw this away
he was winning but now oh the trick your
car gets that gets the queen and gets
the game
important win there very important win
Hikaru could not have lost another game
he's two points and you can see you look
at their faces he's gone into that Zen
mode right Hikaru realizes that he can't
let the game slip away from him anymore
and he's going full in uh Zen mode at
this moment in time and they swap off
into an ending and
um it's a position which is fairly even
at the moment so when you get these
situations the the time is uh is very
important right the time situation
and we know hikaru's camera is on a
slight delay because he is streaming but
we saw you know a little head bopping
there and then a little bit like maybe
not so much so I I don't know what it is
about this game but you see the eval bar
all of a sudden saying white is better
watch out king G4 King H5 I think white
does have the upper hand on the king
side
yes
a little advantage and um
the time situation well hikara is well
up on time so again this is this is
he's up on time but it's it's more
important what's happening on the board
here and those Rooks the white Rooks are
creating a net around the king and we
have a Checkmate on the board another
point
for farrugia yeah Ali Rosa he's in
really good form right now Elite Form
and now your car is going back to his B3
systems his nimzo Larson's I really want
to rename it the Naka just because he
plays it so much uh but you know it has
your great predecessors just like
casparra's books and this position looks
fantastic for alireza I mean you have
this Knight on D4 this bishop on D6
staring towards the white king side now
another piece into the initiative this
is one of those openings that you can
get away with against a regular
Grandmaster
oh there isn't he ain't regular he is
really ridiculously strong
can't forget how strong Ali razor is
right I mean uh the chat you know you
guys in the chat you're all saying 70
Hikaru you've got faith in the great man
but you know Ali Razer he's proving
just how strong he is and um look at the
score line at the moment he's four
points up there is a lot of time to go
there's 31 minutes this is how long the
normal matches are so there is time but
if any racer can keep this Focus
it's going to be very tough to to you
know that that lead is is important four
points is four points and other is is
completely concentrated and oh wow what
a tactical awareness from Hikaru he
gives up his Queen because there
wouldn't politics F2 with a fork he
would have had a rook and two minor
pieces for the queen so what we haven't
said is two minor pieces for a rook and
alireza still in this game and not just
in it apparently better because of the
queen side pressure and now extra
material
oh
he
he hung a piece
yeah and Hikaru
well black seems to be doing very well
here I mean he got the he got the
knights rolling very well White's got
this one chance with his past Pawn
um
I don't think that pawn should be good I
mean look at that spotting and tactic
like that so quickly is just remarkable
and this does win a piece but
still black after losing that in a good
situation
yeah two minor pieces still out class of
Rook so three was too much but two still
enough and here we see that hikar brings
his pieces in that is game over as he
just mops up the remaining pawns and
gets a victory resignation from farooza
and it's back to three points so it
seems like a lot three points is a
pretty big spread but Hikaru has plenty
of time as he tries to make this
comeback happen
it does he still have time to do it and
they're following the same opening
process I mean Daniel mentioned that one
of the problems with Hikaru in that he
found was that hikaru's openings was so
well suited against him but I must say
in in this match I think farrugia has
picked some good openings he's getting
good aggressive positions faroogia loves
attacking and uh he seems to be getting
many positions where he's able to use
that that Genius Like awareness of
tactics that he's showing yes
what's the material account suddenly
black is up a pawn and you know despite
the name there it is farusha with the
black pieces uh they are about equal in
strength for the most part across the
time patrols but today it feels like
farrugia is perfectly on form and he is
now winning the C5 Pawn if he wants it
and he does
white does have a great night though I
mean it is a pawn up for black and
there's a little bit of pressure against
white king that look at White's Knight
in the center of the board it's
beautiful
um if black can ever dislodge that
Knight with a pawn it'll be he's trying
to do that now and oh hang on a minute
what about the black king the black king
now very exposed and white comes in with
a check and you can try to Target that
black king Knight takes pawn and all of
a sudden Hikaru has turned it around and
complete turn around Robert that's me I
mean he's just winning down the H trial
he takes that game and I mean summon he
was down upon but you called it I think
that I wasn't paying enough attention
just that night was better than the
bishop the light score Bishop was
staring into nothing and that Knight was
able to reroute and deliver a win
yeah I mean the games that's coming so
quick and fast as well I mean it is it's
it's incredible to speed they're playing
at speed they're playing the next games
and uh we're getting similar positions
to this I love this last move from Ali
Razer it makes the black king a little
bit weaker black doing well maybe on the
queen side but actually that's not clear
I think white must have an advantage
here
um with you I think that black just
doesn't get access to the move Pawn C4
if black can play that then you open up
the queen side for your pieces and
hikar's in the right thing give me those
dark squares H4 Knight H5 type of ideas
or G5 G4 he can try to attack on the
king side
yes using the explore and look at that
Knight and queen so Hikaru targeting
White's King here and farrugia is now
forced to bring his pieces over to
defend his King there comes another
Knight that black knight coming into
those holes look at that Knight what a
beautiful Square
he can't replaying a great game here but
virus are defending with all his might
as well and and all of a sudden
all of a sudden I think White's better
yeah like I was in that Rook on A6 is
miserably misplaced and there probably
are some tactics against that king
that's standing out on G6
look at the maneuver of that night
Robert and wow a beautiful trick there
from Hikaru
both of them right you couldn't take the
Rook on F5 and you can't take it now
because the Queen's hanging and if you
take the queen of 0.92 check both of
these players spotting brilliant tactics
but Hikaru is up several seconds
I mean incredible chests from both
players they're spotting difficult
tactics in in less than 0.1 of a second
my brain's sort of about four seconds
behind here
and Hikaru winning that game that was an
amazing save that he found that idea of
the night Fork incredible
goodness I feel like I was watching a
pendulum back and forth back and forth
my head didn't know where to turn the
clock the board the Queen said the king
side that was an absolute slugfest and
ikoro Nakamura he takes that game he's
only down by one point so it was a rough
start for him but now he is taking
charge in this match uh disposition okay
you get C7 Pawn Queens are off the board
black doesn't look worse at first glance
but maybe those Queen side pawns are a
bit vulnerable
yeah white has managed to grab a pawn as
well
um so if white can sort of stabilize
then white has good chances but black
pieces they're coming in they come in
nicely the white root looks really bad
F5 I love that move trying to make the
Rook bad
and G4 I try to free the rock but you
can't take either E4 or G4 without
dropping your F2 Pawn so Bishop takes E4
the part oh gosh G3 there's a pin along
that second rank so I think you just
take on F2 and you're ready to promote
that pawn
and there could be now F1 or some tactic
like this yeah it is smothered meat that
you take with the rook and then the
Rooks both them first one Rook to H2
then the second Rook to G2 that's sick
stuff
I think that that's just the only word I
can think of as well it's just sick it
is so sick how these two are playing
it's it's incredible chess this is the
best chest we've seen so far in this
competition tactic after tactic spotting
everything it seems can't we just have
some boring ending soon Robert I need a
bit of time off that's what I don't
normally ask for boring chess but I need
some boring chess come on guys just calm
down no more tactics for a while
you asked for the end game we have an
end game but this isn't an ordinary end
game what is up a pawn but that Bishop
on B8 Knight D7 is about to happen to
trap it but that's what F4 was a good
move from ferrugia I'm worried about the
bishop 1 B8 but this is what happens in
an end game you don't have enough pieces
what are you gonna attack the bishop
with
yeah and that Bishop seems to be getting
out of Dodge and the extra pawn and
ending well it does count
um White Knight jumps into a great
position there and the bishop's still
not out of Harm's Way quite yet
can you move the king back and try and
trap it
black counter-attacking yeah Bishop to
C7 right oh he saves him D6 unbelievable
from both
it is unbelievable and like hopefully
they just repeat and I can have a
breather still not gonna eat even at the
endings there's too many tactics
um it's
still very much in the balance these two
is just not matched between them I think
that's clear they are just going blow
for blow the material left on the board
I mean again amazing tactics there it's
seriously amazing watch this the king is
gonna go back to the H file to stop the
pawn it is objectively a draw but for
the second time in the match Hikaru is
gonna flag alireza in a theoretically
drawn position in the same exact one
that is too tight yeah it's amazing two
times in a row we've had this and it
looks like black should be completely
winning but you either stalemate or you
have to give away your material so
um I don't know if Aly raiser is getting
annoyed by that ending now I would be
I'll be getting really annoyed and uh
you know just part of the game flagging
it's bullet chess
you've got to move quicker if you don't
want to get flagged simple as that
it really is that simple but moving
quickly against Hikaru he'll punish you
on the clock but he'll also punish you
on the board and we see him trying to
push forward on the king side but that
E4 Pawn that is not a healthy pawn and
in fact black is significantly better if
not already objectively almost winning
because that pawn E4 it won't be long
for this board it's already under a
threat twice and is picked off
yeah a nice extra Pawn there for black
and you can see the bishop there
Consolidated by that poor move as well
um so safe extra Pawn uh for Rouge this
is a game that he would well he probably
needs to win psychologically to get back
on track he is a point up
and he's pushing forwards this is what
another thing I like about Addy Razor's
play
um he doesn't when he gets an advantage
he doesn't suddenly try to lock up the
shop even though nice tactic uh spotted
there he keeps trying to push it through
he's got some pressure against the black
king Rooker five is a nice move so
objectively this position you see the
evaluation should be a draw and now the
clock is evening up and D5 I really like
that strike from other razor but hey
cars go for checkmate G4 and Rook G7 was
a mating threat that's why black had to
play H5 to vacate the H6 Square
one thing that is is certainly in
hikaru's favor is that he's slightly
quicker on the clock he's already
flagged Rouge twice
um and here it's an equal ending but
because of the clock time this flagging
oh hang a minute what happened there
just brilliant what happened there
that's all you know he brought the king
Into The Bishop's line of sight then
Unleashed a discovery that won him of
rock the way that both of these players
are playing this match is superb we are
so fortunate to watch this but I don't
think that black is fortunate right now
because isn't White's up a piece so
Hikaru he evens up the match and then he
drops a piece
yeah he does uh seven and a half all and
we have 20 minutes to go uh but he's a
piece down in this one and farouza
really can't he can't he can't really
get on a run this is one thing I've
noticed from watching Hikaru if Hikaru
gets in a run he's just like you know
he's leveling up uh every single game
he's getting that that energy and hikara
I think resigns that one quickly so he
can get on with the next game yeah it
doesn't feel nice to be down by a piece
forever and you know he it others have
so much time left that it wasn't worth
it to a car to go on and now in this
position what is white done in this game
yeah you have the bishop here but your
King's still in the center black is just
pressing forward and I just feel like
it's a healthier structure for black
overall and the eval Bar says Robert you
know what you're talking about this is
actually totally fine for white
I'm I'm with you Robert I'm with you I I
don't I don't believe the evaluation but
I believe in their s you know let's just
leave the evaluation bar behind I I
think black's got all the pressure here
White's pieces they're all snuggling on
the first rank I mean they're they're
being lazy and uh black is attacking so
I I would much rather be black yeah but
now hikara says oh wait you want H4 to
take on G3 I don't care let's trade
Knights Our Queen is getting active the
F7 Pawn now the f file is open be very
very careful if you are uh alireza but
Queen E3 is I don't that's not a
question mark the evaluation is saying
it's about even get that question mark
out of here you don't you can't give
question marks unless it's a mouse slip
that gives away a queen or something
like that get that out of here whoa what
giving up F7
uh Queen H6 is just saving the day there
otherwise it would have been checkmates
and all of a sudden after that tactics
it says that black is better and this is
the kind of depth that these players are
seeing it's not one or two moves in the
blink of an eye they're seeing five move
tactics it's it's so so deep meanwhile
oh Rook f8 oh check them out
completely blundered into it and you
know what happened Simon he was
defending really well but then he paused
and I think when he paused he looked at
his clock and suddenly I'm down on time
when he was maybe even or even a couple
seconds ahead so Hikaru was relentless
putting the pressure on the black king
but farouja I think he just had that
Split Second bit of nerves and actually
every time a car evens it up he follows
it up with what seems like a very bad
game because fruit is completely winning
and where 15 Moves In
yeah I mean it's it's it's a yo-yo it's
eight and a half or if you wanted a
match this is a match
um but you're right Hikaru is getting in
trouble maybe he's relaxing with the
leveling the score it's a very easy
thing to do you level the score and
you're like
but you can't relax in chess it's it you
have to play all the way to the end
white doing very well here white or Pawn
up White's Bishop cutting the board in
two there you can't get past that bishop
and look at those pieces just floating
in a check is threatened and maybe The
Rook can just slide over here but first
of all using Harry to create more Frets
he wants to set up a meeting net Hikaru
gets to the back rank just in time Rook
f8 Volvo Rook h8 is the main idea but
look at other years ago he's just
trading pieces taking Parts he's up two
pawns but Hikaru is kind of up one Pawn
over there on the king side but the a
pawn seems too fast
the a pawn must be too fast here it's
two squares away from queening let's see
what tricks black can do any tries a
rook move but losing The Rook there
pre-moving in a lost position and again
an eraser taking a one point lead but
this is where Hikaru is dangerous Hikaru
wants to keep Toe to Toe with Ali razor
and as soon as he goes a point down he
fights back
yeah I think that Hikaru needs to find a
bit of consistency because he's
consistently ahead on the clock but
something about the early stages of some
of these games have not been and this is
another one right black is just much
better because you have a healthy Pawn
structure and you're pushing in the
center so Hikaru he is struggling out of
the gates
he is struggling he's getting he's
getting bad positions I mean he's he's
got all the tricks he's got all the
skills but the openings are not going
very well and does black have some
really good move like D4 maybe he's
calculating D4 this is also a good
option
well maybe not actually because Hikaru
is now attacking yeah nikara can take
this E4 Pawn so suddenly it went from an
awesome Center for black and to a pawn
down position where white is the one on
the offensive so Hikaru he's been
playing very fast he's playing very well
right now and yeah Hikaru is uh stealing
a couple pawns but his King is also a
bit open
yeah I would not be Rook date C3 looks
very tempting here uh I will not be
entirely happy if I was Whitehead just
because my King has a lot of air around
it and the evaluation bar thinks that
White's completely wrong here but
I would be scared okay now the Queens
are off you can breathe a bit uh a bit
more safer and white has a big two-point
Advantage here and the score is what's
the score Robert it's level again right
it's once again tied there's no
separation between these two and it goes
for both of them I know you know
sometimes like Hikaru wins a nice game
or wins a bishop end game that should
theoretically be drawn then if why is
there a king on D2
slipped in a critical situation there he
just Mouse slipped and that has given
ikaru a pretty good position I mean he
Mount slips actually he's okay still
I mean normally with my mouth slip I
have to resign immediately what happened
there right we saw Daniel Mouse slip and
loses Queen and mouse-ups usually make
your position collapse but White's up a
pawn here and oh that was a nice move
though it's Bishop C4 Rook takes E4 and
he goes back to F1 for that reason
yeah and still it looks like Hikaru must
I mean again evaluation but I'm not
always believing because it must be
black he's got the pressure here surely
but just defending
never doubt the computer I've got to
learn this the evaluation bar is God I'm
just a mere I'm a mere
I don't know hasn't
this whole game has been like super
ridiculous uh where what's going on here
is thinking Queen DHS King G7 he's going
for it but that's apparently losing
there was oh I think he had to go Bishop
seven first but I only had to do that
because the eval bar reacted but you
know what just happened there
was sick like alireza Mouse slips then
he gets an advantage and he walks into a
discover check which is the right
decision at that point so both these
players have such a firm grasp of
tactics and knowing when to you know
give your opponent what seems like a
chance but they've calculated even in
Split seconds that it's not actually
that dangerous
yeah it's an incredible play from both
of them Robert and I mean you know we
have a situation now though and I don't
know if this is one of the first times
in the match where Hikaru has taken the
lead it might be the first situation I
mean really hard to keep on track even
for us commentators but Hikaru has now
got a one point lead and you can see
Andy Razer getting a little bit annoyed
there look at his body language that's
not a good sign uh you know because you
suddenly feel it you think I've been
leading this match all the way why am I
behind what am I doing and if you think
like that that's when things go horribly
wrong and you can go into a rot Hikaru
also talking a bit more so this is a
dangerous part of the match for Ali
Razer he loses this which he probably
should do here be two points behind so
it's a this is danger time for alireza
it really is and there is 12 minutes and
about 45 seconds remaining so even if he
goes down two he will still have time to
cut in to that lead that Hikaru has and
Hikaru is just pushing for Queen G7 F6
it's like an alpha Zero game where the
queen is on age shade uh White actually
isn't even up any material but black
can't move in fact that's Checkmate to
the queen
I would just resign this position out of
because out of nausea uh that that Queen
was just too sickening to to play on
anymore and uh Hikaru now takes a two
point lead so
um farouza you gotta fight back in I
love this what you do when when times
are bad Robert you push Harry the H Pawn
that's what you do you throw the H Pawn
towards your opponent and you go for the
kill and I love what he's doing here
look at this this is a razor on fire in
we go with a queen Maybe forcing the
king up the board it didn't like Queen
takes H7 which is a free Pawn with check
uh maybe they're okay it still says
white is much better it takes some time
uh but not because of that move
apparently what is
it's too complicated for me
yeah I'm with you there I I can't keep
up with their their skill level here I
don't think many players could uh in
Hikaru now you can see his confidence is
growing in this match he's two points up
he had a lost position but he's finding
resource after resource saying that
white is still doing very well here
this is a game I think Ali razor must
win he doesn't win this
the match is starting to slip away and
look at this both minor pieces for white
defend that pass Pawn white is now up
just a single pawn it looks very very
good for him his oppon is so Advanced
but hikar is doing what he does best we
saw that opening Sizzle of his past and
that's a great move you can't take on a
D7 because Rook H7 check resignation
alireza he once again strikes back it's
a one-point match
crazy stuff that we keep seeing
crazy stuff just one point between these
two Gladiators and um there is 11
minutes left so there's plenty of play
in this match and here Hikaru with the
white pieces
but he hasn't been getting great
positions with white
um Ali racer proving that the Sicilian
is a perfect opening for him he's
getting Dynamic play a good break in the
center liberating blacks pieces and
Black's better hit black is definitely
better again look at those pieces that
white hasn't developed it and the queen
going to be seven saying your
wants you want you what was that about
development no you're not getting out of
there the B2 Pawn is threatened so black
has two pawns on the queen side but
they're taking care of all three of
White's pawns and look at the
maneuvering of the pieces open the D
file up I have two Rooks there I would
maybe go Rook D1 right now that's what
he plays I like to take over the first
rank thank you very much
yeah I I saw someone in the chat just
mentioning I need to watch this in slow
motion and uh I must admit I do feel
that quite a lot when I'm trying to
comment about this I think I'm gonna go
bed tonight with moves just flashing
through my mind without any
understanding of chess.com can you
please create a slow motion button
for when we watch these Legends of the
gameplay so I could you know when we're
watching it back we can just slow it
down a little bit so I can get my cup of
tea so I can breathe to do some yoga
it's it's so quick and fast and black is
winning here but white now creating a
bit of counter play oh he missed it he
had to go see three because Rook D2 is
meat so it wasn't just about pushing the
C Pawn he had a Checkmate pattern and
now I would say that white is playing
for a win
and now it's black why
yeah oh it's a big game and look at the
E Pawn the E Pawn is coming through that
was a really important window and uh his
level is level again is it level again
it is yeah that was a win for fun two in
a row we're tied 11 and a half eleven
and a half at faruga now takes over the
white pieces after evening up this match
the pawn structure this reminds me of
the uh the match we saw earlier where
Bortnick kept getting these double pawns
but he would get an outpost for his
Knight here I think because the king is
weak that white should be the side for
choice
yeah and and it's all about that King
say to mentioned many times before in
bullet chess you want to have the safer
King this is a great it looks like a
great defensive move but the evaluation
bar does not agree
um this Rook coming in and now white
should be able to pick up a pawn here oh
but look at that tactic it it doesn't
even work but what a tactic it was you
know I was so busy calculating could
that Rook take a free pawn and speaking
of three pawns he wants to nibble
because that Queen can go all the way
back to G1 so his Queen is gonna take on
B7 with check two extra pawns for weight
but now it's one and this King may not
be able to escape all the checks
black has at least a draw here but
Hikaru wondering if he can try to bring
his Knight in somehow to uh get some
advantage and I think he probably had to
take the draw and well it's 12 all with
seven minutes 45 to go if this does not
go down to tie break I would be shocked
I can't see how one player can get a
two-point lead in this match it's just
so close it really is and look at this
game weight is throwing all an avalanche
of Pawns up the king side and black
saying your king looks okay for now but
there we see the advantage starting to
turn a little bit and queen F2 was a
mistake I'm not entirely sure what we're
taking advantage of it but Knight V6 was
hikaru's plan and that Knight on B6 has
to retreat and can black open up the a
file that's the big question
it looks like White's coming through
first though right I mean those white
pawns they're getting right near to the
black king but where is the Breakthrough
black has got some kind of blockade and
I think hikaru's uh and a bit of
premature articulation here he's gone a
little bit too fast in the position and
uh did he not I mean you could have done
this a little bit slower it's Black's
time to attack now yeah rookie eight
Queen A5 should deliver a checkmating
idea but the big problem for black is
the king is in the corner and they think
they took you take back that is going to
be a Checkmate but oh The Rook was
hanging
what in the world they're zigging and
zagging and I can't keep up
Robert I can't keep up with this as well
where's that slow motion button yeah
this old man needs the slow motion and
it looked like white was completely
winning but now the white king is the
king that is in trouble and uh
um this white king is trying to get out
of all the problems
can he survive here whoa
absolutely ridiculous draw there and I
think a car went up to D4 knowing that I
was going to Queen E5 is hovering over
the square but I also think he realized
no don't do that because if I play to
win I'm playing the lose and so we still
have a tied match we have a locked match
we have a locked position right now and
we'll see can black get in this move B5
that's the break that you need to get
some play over there on the queen side
whereas white is very very solid in this
position I have to say I like fruits
chances once again
it's like but you know um again who's
who's got the attack and black has the
attack here
um you can oh okay if you can lock it
down on the king side
before we have a chance to discuss any
position it's a totally dim position
Robert that's the problem I'm getting
they're moving so quick finding some
accurate ways to respond and it might
just be very much in the balance here
black getting a lot of pressure actually
now yes what's the score way too soon
right look at this black sacrifice the
pawn but was completely dominating
because the side that controls the pawn
breaks is typically the same with the
advantage and black control them took
this Pawn on B2 then only for the G5
Pawn can be captured and H3 might be
next
yeah and under five minutes now and it's
danger zone because if one side wins
they win the next one they go to that
golden two point Edge and black is still
dominating here because the white king
is absolutely trapped the sea pawns
coming through Hikaru taking a big big
win there and if Hikaru wins the next
one he gets that golden two-point lead
so uh farouza with the black pieces this
is a pressure game for him yeah what a
game there by Hikaru have to give him
his roses his Round of Applause that was
really excellent stuff and now Hikaru
with the white side going for an attack
watch out there's E5 ideas in many
positions but you will remove the
attacker with Knight takes D3 in these
positions so be very very careful if you
are farooza he gets rid of that most
aggressive piece I have to say that in
classical games I like this from the
white side in bullet I tend to like the
pair of Bishops
yes and
well okay we have that situation the
Bishops versus and the Knights if King
can again keep itself safe I'm really
liking black here and it looks like the
black king is not in really any danger
Hikaru opening up the position and
that's very dangerous because the two
Bishops love open structures and I think
the winning piece it could well be
Black's light Square Bishop on that
diagonal pointing all the way towards
White's queen and king
um so farouza he's I think this is he's
got to again we have games where you
must get a result and with three minutes
to go this is a game where Frozen I
think he must win this position and he
won't get a better position than this
complicated though he oh Queen dropped
his Queen what was he doing dropped his
Queen oh my gosh you could have taken E4
with check for example but he gives up
his Queen and now his Rook is hanging
too he's got to resign he needs to start
the next game as soon as possible
he's got to resign here there's nothing
to do and it's it's going to be a
two-point lead as soon as I say it the
commentator's curse
the commentator's curse I say that he's
got to win that game and what happened
there you think he just drops his Queen
that's as simple as that
yeah no I mean he was trying to go for
an attack he couldn't see the finale the
devastating blow and he just gives up
his Queen so now alrissa with the white
pieces he needs to win this game and he
might play his H4 H5 stuff he gave him a
pawn over there on the queen side but
he's going for that King set Bishop
takes C5 that was a pin
it was it was pimp yeah
I mean he's good he's going for straight
in with the attack instead and he's
getting rid of this dark Square bishop
and this is a really just double-edged
situation Black's attacking whites
attacking black might be threatening a
rook sacrifice and here comes Harry the
H on
um I mean you know I I for Ali razor
you've got to win this game if we want
to keep the match going
white has to land a blow I I think based
on how much time is left alireza can
afford to draw this game and he will get
one more opportunity reminder to
everybody it's win by two points so if
aleriza can win at least one game before
the match clock for the expires he's in
this but he's losing this game there's a
rook and a queen right in his King's
face and I think there's Queen A3 and
then Rook takes A2 and queen slides into
B2 and that's Main and that would be the
match
oh in this one minute 20 or so left and
the white king is in a desperate
situation and the time and he's what and
he's one he's gone three points up look
at that
he is nodding his head is that like the
Crazy Frog it reminds me of something
but that that is the match that I feel
is the match
unbelievable we see the comments from
chat coming in there Hikaru good uh
Hikaru is not good Hikaru is great uh
this is greatness on full display he was
down early in the match it didn't seem
like he was in his best form but that's
what alireza does to people I think
sometimes we think one uh games aren't
going your way oh they're they're
playing badly not I think Ali Rizza was
giving Hikaru as the biggest challenge
that you could possibly give Hikaru and
he's gonna win this match he might even
win this game to make it a four point
spread but it was much closer than the
final score could indicate because this
felt knotted up throughout the whole way
right it only started going in hikaru's
favor towards the end of the match to
the start of the match
um alireza was was doing very very well
and uh yeah it's a sign of a champion
obviously to to fight back so well but
this to me the matches I've seen has
been such a such an incredibly high
standard for bullet chess I mean I think
if most grand Masters are playing some
of the tactics they've been playing in
classical chess they'd be pretty happy
but in bullet chess what a match that
was and I think now we can see we have
the result and we have Hikaru going
through and Robert
well uh one of the best matches I've
ever seen yeah that was epic and that
word is often overused as cliche but not
here as Hikaru Nakamura stays in the
winners bracket he beats alireza farooza
make its Grand Final he sends alireza
down to the losers final where he will
await the winner of Daniel narodiski
versus Magnus Carlsen but farouza he
lost the match but you know that final
score four point difference between two
that's not what it was this match could
have gone either way and a couple breaks
would have changed it but Hikaru we
showed that video before the start of
the match Simon he's so darn good he's
so darn resourceful and he's a nightmare
opponent for anybody he just doesn't go
now without swinging he refuses to lose
yeah I mean he he never gives up and he
he seems to find gears upon gears I mean
that you know a sign of a true champion
you get in a bad situation you try to
give it your all and you have to find
something and Hikaru just finds
something you know I'm not even sure
what it is but he's got
um just unlimited next gears to go
through
um a brilliant match we we have to
remind everyone that luckily for uh
farouza Ali you know Ali Roger's fans
he's not out of the competition because
that's the first time he's lost so he's
gonna get his second chance but so far
Hikaru proving dominant winning all of
his games yeah Hikaru is an absolute
force and alresa stays alive he will
play tomorrow as will hikaras he awaits
the winner of the losers bracket but
before we send you a good uh a goodbye I
can't even speak it's been such a long
day we're gonna have an interview with
Hikaru Nakamura so Simon and I will
regain our composure we'll refresh
ourselves and when we're back it's akara
Nakamura so leave your questions in the
chat for when we return
that is still plenty of options and
opportunities left all right next one
you ready yes let's do it asparium study
yes
looks kind of familiar
but
okay yeah Rook D2 repeat
so how do you start Queen A3 rookie two
rookie two d206 A3 it would be two okay
two will be one very nice very nice
well done
okay
so it's Queen A3 check A2
then Rook B2 Rook A3 Rook B2 not entry
would be one very nice yeah very nice
yes
impressive knowledge another study I
mean if you know this one
because it might be impressed why to
move okay that's all I don't know
so it's 10 seconds as well 10 seconds oh
yeah
the bishop B6 C5 V8 uh B6 yes
nca4 H4 H4 uh
now I have to yes you can get five and
H5 and King E4 yeah very nice
as king E4 for the final move Bishop B6
Queen B6 C5 Queen B8 B6 King C8 King D4
yes H4 and king of five H5 and King E4
TV four back yeah very nice
well done okay this one is a bit
difficult
so I guess Bishop takes B6 yes Queen B6
C5 yes Queen B8
B6 you can see a C7
Queen B7
uh C7 might not be correct oh
oh okay
yes yes H4
you have Apollo G3 H5 and H6 right yes
okay the king F5 H5 exactly yeah very
nice that's the one yes
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
what a match that was and we are treated
delighted to be joined by Hikaru
Nakamura Hikaru first off
congratulations how do you feel having
taken down alarisa
yeah I mean it was a very a very tough
match obviously I got up to a pretty bad
start and it just felt like I was trying
to claw my way back into it after the
start um I mean I think he start off
really really well and it was sort of in
the middle there was a period where it
just seemed like he ran out of steam
kind of um because I mean it's obviously
like I would win a few then he would win
a few and would get back like three or
four I think like two times that
happened
um so yeah I mean I think um you know I
think it's just you stay in the match
you try to just do all that you can to
um to find a way through
uh yeah brilliant match to Hikaru loads
of people uh just really enjoying that
one including myself and um could you
tell us how you think uh this match
compared to other uh bullet chess
matches that you've had with alireza
yeah I mean the the obvious match to
compare it with is the match in 2021 uh
still during the pandemic where olly
recipe I mean I think it was a one hour
format if I'm not mistaken it's funny
because that match was actually almost
the exact opposite of this match and
that I started out very fast I think I
was up by three or four and then there
was a there was a break uh so that chest
con could run some ads
um and because of that alirez was able
to come back stronger and then he ended
up taking the lead and winning that
match at the very end so uh you know I
that's the match I think of of course
like I said it was completely the
opposite but nonetheless I think both of
these matches show that Ali Reza is no
joke at all I mean he found some amazing
it was like I thought there was this end
game where he plays Bishop takes A7 and
I think I ended up winning that game but
I thought that that was the game where I
felt he was going to turn around I was
going easily and then he found this like
Bishop V8 Knight D5 F4 all this stuff
and he didn't end up losing the bishop
and um yeah he's just I mean he's a
great ball player
well you flagged him in the same exact
position two different times it was
theoretically drawn positions I mean did
you feel throughout that match and was
it your preparation that the clock would
be one of your biggest advantages
um I mean I didn't think that the I
wasn't thinking of the clocks main
advantage but you know the one thing
that I remember from Ali Raza uh when I
played him in 2021 is he he actually has
become what I would say the the new uh
the new Andrew Tang I think for lack of
a better way of putting it where uh
Andrew Tang used to be the guy who got
really low on time like maybe around
10-ish seconds or a little bit below 10
seconds and then just like boom boom
boom play every move and just blow you
off the board and I do remember even
from the last match that Ali Reza has
that ability where he can get really low
and you think you're gonna win but he's
able to show just amazing technique and
um you know I did that's sort of around
like I would say game five or six was in
my mind um that I needed to try and
press him on the clock and I I think you
know I started changing my openings a
little bit I started getting certain
positions that were a little bit easier
to play I don't want to give away too
much but during the match I was
tinkering quite a bit I think I sort of
figured it out by by like the end of the
match what what I should do
and how do you think your uh bullet
chess game has uh sort of evolved since
past the editions of this championships
well I mean I think uh well I think
first of all I've gone a little bit
worse than I used to be but I think
everyone else has just gotten much
better I mean Ollie Reza I probably
would have like double adopt him like
Amino Haney and if it's like five or six
years ago but uh you know I think I've
gotten maybe a little bit slower
actually you know it's kind of prophetic
because because a lot of things I've
said on my stream about things to not
avoid or things to avoid uh in in these
matches happen today first of all I was
a little bit slow my brain was freezing
up in some critical moments where I
couldn't find a move and I would use
like five or six seconds um and all
these things were happening today so
um you know it's just uh It's just tough
everyone's getting better and you know I
still can compete but there's gonna come
a time probably in the next year or two
when uh when I won't be able to uh to
win these matches but at least today it
seemed to be good enough
yeah you're a great champion and
everyone loves to see you play and they
also love to ask some questions so we're
gonna feature this question from chilimo
and this is a really good one do you
think the result would have been
different if the match was 30 instead of
45 minutes
oh yeah absolutely I mean again this is
another thing that I that I was saying
before the event sorry I was very
worried about the 30 minute format
because I do feel that if you get off to
a slow start in the 30 minute format
you're just toast I mean if this was a
30 minute match I'd lose this match um
and actually now that I think about it I
did play alireza in 2020 I think uh in
the bullet Chess Championship and that
was I believe a 30 minute match and
quite similar to this one the score
didn't get to I think six and a half two
and a half but I think he was up by two
or three from the get-go and then I won
like four in a row to win the match at
the very end um but 30 minutes is
obviously very scary to play and I I
think that 45 minutes gave gave me that
gave me a chance I'm very lucky I played
him um when I did rather than when it
was a 30 minute formats in 30 minutes I
would have just lost this match because
also when I was down by like the four
games I wouldn't start stressing because
with less time you start stressing when
you're like 15 minutes and and you're
down by that much so um it I would have
lost the match if it was 30 for sure
and we have another a question from the
chat here and I think a lot of people
are wondering how how excited you are I
don't know if that's the right word but
how you're feeling about facing
potentially Magnus Carlson in the final
here
yeah I mean I really do I really don't
care I mean it's hard to believe that
anything can type today whether I win or
lose
um but yeah it's I mean if I play Magnus
that's that's fine I mean Matt Magus has
to beat Daniel and Ollie Reza I mean if
we get there I'll take my chances but as
I've said in relation to the chess
championships has the same format as
this it's great when you uh when you
stay alive in the winners bracket
because it just means you you avoid so
many dangerous players I mean I I don't
care I mean having to play one of Magnus
or alireza I'm happy with that I mean if
if you told me tomorrow I have to play
Daniel and then Magnus and Ollie runs
again like I'd probably like just like
not show up if I had to play all those
monsters but
um yeah I think um I think if I play
Magnus it's great again he seemed really
on form
um at moma's today but he has to beat
Daniel he's got to beat Ali Reza I mean
I I would say that uh I if all the rest
of the place where he did against me
today I think he's going to beat Magnus
but
um I mean we just we just wait and see
okay well I was gonna ask you to make a
prediction so instead I will ask the
very serious question coming from Max in
chat seriously Karu barbier Oppenheimer
sorry what
Barbie or Oppenheimer pick one
oh sorry okay sorry I didn't catch the
the e at the end of Barbie
um I mean I would I would go watch
Barbie if you made me pick one
um
that's what that's what I would do
uh well you know what no shame in that I
think everybody in chat most people if
they're honest they would probably
choose the same but hey guard will let
you well but you know Robert you know
it's 2023 you know you have to be like
kind of more correct about things in
this day and age so I I think for that
reason a lot of people would say
Oppenheimer let's leave it at that
nah I mean I'm I'm more excited to see
Barbie myself Simon you got to get in
here you're at the tiebreaker
yeah I'll go Barbie as well it seems
like why not you know
oh well icaro I know you're on stream so
we'll let you get back to your awesome
Community but congratulations that was
seriously an amazing match
yeah thank you so much and obviously I
mean a big shout out to all the fans who
watch and obviously Ollie Rose I mean it
was a great match and I mean if he very
easily could have won it too so I think
it was great for everybody and looking
forward to playing either all around
Magnus uh tomorrow so we'll see how it
goes
okay excited to see you then uh hikar
you guys best of luck tomorrow
well that was an awesome interview after
an awesome match in Hikaru Nakamura he's
made his way to the Grand Final and he
awaits somebody from the losers bracket
he just named Magnus or alireza and
Magnus has to get through Daniel
naroditsky and then whoever wins between
them has to get through alireza just for
the chance to play against Hikaru but I
I noticed that he doesn't think that
Donna's chances are that high and I
think that's fair Magnus and alereza are
the favorite from the losers bracket but
Dania the way he's been playing it means
that he can definitely swing with Magnus
or alarism
yeah I mean uh it's going to be very
interesting I mean I don't really know
what to say after today it was that last
match had just kind of blown my mind a
little bit I mean I was trying to keep
up with the tactics and I'm normally
able to follow most of the stuff being a
grand master but in that one it was just
too much of it the speed that they were
thinking was uh was from another world
it was just remarkable and I think we've
watched something uh quite special in
that match
it definitely was special that's a good
word for it and something that's special
but maybe not you're featuring super
gems but superstars of their online
creation sphere POG Champs five it
starts Late July the wait is over 16 of
the world's biggest creators will go
head to head in the greatest event in
amateur chess brought to you by
chess.com and pop Champs Legend Ludwig
watch your favorite creators like cutie
Cinderella Sea Dog VA xqc I did a thing
and more fight for their share of a 100
000 prize fund and a ticket to the live
finals yes live finals in Los Angeles
use the command POG in chat for all the
details and that starts in Late July
before any of that of course we have
tomorrow's a championship Friday in the
bullet Chess Championship so Simon any
final thoughts about today and what to
expect tomorrow
I'm I mean it was a great day at
yesterday there was so much uh just
brilliant stuff going on everywhere I
mean the Highlight was clearly that last
match but uh we we had uh Magnus Carlson
also playing uh um you know a very high
standard and um getting to the sort of
Crescendo of the whole competition to
the end we're gonna we're gonna find out
who the champion is and I know
um sort of we heard Hikaru maybe not
right off Magnus of course you can never
write off Magnus but saying it's going
to be incredibly hard for him to go
through first Dania and then Ali razor
but one thing we know about Champions
and people like Magnus is that which
Hikari did today is that they fight that
much harder when their back is tied
against the wall and I can still see a
Magnus Carlson versus Hikaru Nakamura
final and uh you know I think well I
don't even know if it's secretly but
that that's the final I want to see and
it's still very possible well Magnus is
going to win this event he'll have to
win four matches tomorrow because first
he scores off against Daniel naroditski
the winner of that one takes on alireza
farugia the winner of that goes up to
the Grand Final to take on Hikaru
Nakamura and if someone from the losers
bracket wins they'll have to win a
second time it's a double elimination
format so somebody may have to win four
total matches to take the first place
prize but coming up soon is the blitz
champ Stanford you will not want to miss
that that starts I think in like 30
minutes so get a little bit of a
refreshment walk around he had some
fresh air and then come back for more
chess continue celebrating International
chess with blitz Champs right after this
[Music]
yes hard work hard work following the
chest you know
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign